there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hey you guys it's us again
we're back once again for another
episode this is episode 160 yeah it's
gonna be a good one
this one yeah I wanted to cover like
kind of a lot of ground on this one I
don't know how long it's gonna end up
because I have like a lot of different
things that I wanted to cover and I
think well I mentioned this I don't
remember what episode it was well though
it was a movie review or a regular
episode or whatever but I actually got
the idea to do this show from a few
weeks back we saw the psychological
horror movie called compliance yeah from
2012 and I got really interested in it
because it says at the end that it was
you know based on a real event yeah so I
kind of started looking into the history
behind that and you know what the truth
of it was and stuff the movie was
actually pretty accurate like after
right now we're watching it and I was
going like jani man this is this is a
true story
oh yeah when this happened cuz I saw the
video evidence from it
yeah what was happening was this guy was
calling all these fast-food restaurants
pretending to be a cop getting the guys
that worked there to undress the teenage
girls yeah they're pretty damn [ __ ] yeah
for some weird yeah she stole something
take her clothes off yeah and they were
doing it there were variations of it um
it happened like an alarming amount like
over about a 10 to 12 year period yeah
um they don't know if it was the same
guy that did all of them but you know
I'll get into that a little bit later on
yeah we're on the bottom of this what
this was all about why why we're down
the window yeah exactly and so once I
started researching that which they
usually called the strip search phone
call scam that's what it's Wikipedia
page is called anyway so once I started
researching that from there that kind of
linked off to prank net which is sort of
a loose collective of online douchebags
who kind of like got their jollies out
of doing similar [ __ ] like you know
calling hotels calling
system of getting people to do
ridiculous things disgusting things
things that damaged the restaurant or
the hotel or whatever I mean they cause
like thousands and thousands of dollars
with the damage and [ __ ] like that so I
got into all of that kind of stuff and I
found all that really interesting
although the dudes that pulled this
should that [ __ ] off I hate them with
the heat of a thousand suns they're just
like the biggest [ __ ] contains in the
universe but like you know other than
like serial killers and [ __ ] but you
know what I mean so I got I kind of got
interested in that and then that kind of
got me back into like my old like
college psychology days like thinking
about you know obedient studies
conformity studies the Milgram
experiment the Solomon Asch conformity
studies that type of stuff so I kind of
wanted to get into this whole thing
about you know about these different
kinds of scams about obedience about how
people react to it you know [ __ ] like
that I just thought it would make like a
really interesting topic like I said
it's I have so many tendrils like in my
notes and stuff so I don't know how long
this is gonna go on or how organized
it's gonna be all this Imagi all this
mass psychology and conformity and
obedience something that's real relevant
to the debt to to today too you can see
you know multi media companies and mass
media companies using psychology on
people and yeah all come CIA CIA was big
into it they were actually contracting
out universities to try to do all the
work to figure out how to control the
masses and you know it's all using those
same elements of mass psychology we'll
get into it yeah it's a it's just kind
of like an interesting thing and I've
always been interested in like you know
the Milgram experiment and stuff like
that yeah propaganda propaganda so we'll
kind of get into all that too cuz that's
like I said that's relevant to the you
know to the phone scams because you know
you're you're essentially thinking that
the person on the other end of the phone
is an authority figure and is telling
you what to do and a kind of scary
amount of people will do it if they
think the person on the other end like
knows what they're talking about or if
they're authoritative enough so we'll
kind of get into that in a little bit
now before we do that let's do some
litterer little shout outs just like the
past couple
weeks my book faceless villain vol 3 his
out covers the years 1980 to 1999
unsolved murders sales have been strong
on it too it's even read it's even
selling all the old ones
well yeah cuz I feel like like I said
now that the three volumes are out
people are like oh hey I was yeah I
guess it is a trilogy just like it's
gonna be so yeah so some people actually
went back I was like I said I'm thinking
about maybe in the future like maybe
next year in a year or two like doing
like doing them all in one big book like
a hardback like with you know maybe
pictures and charts and [ __ ] like that
but I don't know I'll see if I want to
do that like you're two down the line so
they're all definitely gonna keep
writing though there's gonna be you know
new subjects and new things to talk
about well yeah and I always I always
got to write something I always gotta be
something no matter what it is yes she's
got a big fiction book coming out big
compilation it'll be out a few months
yeah I've only got a little bit left on
the audiobook for life and then and then
that'll be up in a few weeks probably
yes I'm sending more consumer-friendly
packages that have all these little
bitty books that's gonna be in one big
yeah I mean this one was fairly big to
begin with but I you know I added some
stories to it and like I said did an
audio but he wanted it to be at least
400 pages
yeah which didn't you know which need
ever had before anything around that
size sales better just does that well
yeah like I don't want to buy
substantive book well yeah lion I think
I said this on last week's show it's
just it just seems like you know you
feel like you're getting your money's
worth that's basically what it is so
yeah so there's that whole thing and
then also I would like to thank our
newest patron whose name is Tina
so hello there thank you very much for
your support and also big shout out to
friend of the show Melanie who sent us
another one of her very generous PayPal
donations a big shout out to Melanie
thank you very much you guys for your
support we appreciate everything that
you guys do if you'd like to support the
show hit us up on patreon yep or like I
said go to the blog and there's also a
little PayPal button there that goes to
my I know it says Hollow Earth that's my
graphic design company so it is mate
don't they don't like freak out about it
I do like eventually have to change that
logo
at this point I haven't figured how to
do all right so let's start by talking
about the infamous strip-searched phone
call scam yeah now even though it's
called that like singular there were
actually about 70 of these similar type
of things reported over 30 US states
over a period of a dozen years as I said
they don't know if it was the same guy
that was responsible for them a man was
arrested but it didn't work out the way
everyone might have hoped the one that
compliance was based on was one
particular you know was probably the
worst one of like all the ones that
happen so we'll get into that a little
bit too but that but he had done a bunch
prior to that so what this guy would do
the first two calls that were reported
were actually in 1992 one of these was
in North Dakota and one was in Nevada
not a lot of details about those two
like Tom was saying earlier pretty much
what he would do he would call it was
almost always a fast-food restaurant
sometimes grocery stores he would do
grocery stores as well and he would say
he would either say that he was a cop or
that he was someone like in the
corporate office of that chain or
whatever and then he would tell them it
was usually like you know oh somebody
that works there has been stealing or
they have drugs or something like that
you have to detain them strip search
them and make them do like all these
humiliating yeah and somebody call up he
wouldn't even know the girl's name but
he would ask it in a way to get the
people to actually give up somebody's
name yes I just like the way what's that
redheaded girl's name that's working now
you know that kind of stuff you know
yeah it was like that's like yeah yeah
that's her yeah that's essentially what
it stuff like that so yeah so like I
said the first two were reported like
the first two notable incidents of a
reported happened in 1982 one in North
Dakota and one in Nevada now in November
of 2000 there was one that was kind of
similar to the later one that the movie
was based on and this happened at a
McDonald's just like the one that movie
was based on this happened in leach
field kentuc
now the guy called and said he was a cop
and he said that one of the customers in
the restaurant was a suspected sex
offender and that she had to undress and
stand in front of him as bait so that
they said that officers could rush in
and catch him so that was like one of
the first notable that was one of the
first notable incidents and that that
also happened in Kentucky just like the
later one did that was that the movie
was based on so yeah
so yes so this guy it's like [ __ ]
calling and like people are doing it
which you know and I'll say this right
off the bat it's like you know it's easy
to say in hindsight that you just get
some phone call from some Rando who says
he's a cop or says he's like from the
corporate office or whatever and he
tells you to do something like that you
know you'd be like nah man and stuff but
you have to think too that a lot of
these places and I think the reason why
this dude targets fast-food restaurants
and stuff like that is because a lot of
the employees there are kids you know
they're like teenagers and [ __ ] like
that yeah like rural areas where yeah
most really weren't street savvy most of
them were and the 90s was just a
different time I mean it just was it was
pre-internet yeah Authority was
respected more information was kind of
they were kind of like low information
people everybody was even I was yeah you
just couldn't have you didn't have
access to information like you have back
then yeah you know no man so we didn't
really know about scams in the you know
or what a scam actually was best a phone
scam yeah it's so it's easier to dupe
people and you wouldn't even know what
was going on in your local area really
yeah because it's just you only watch
the only hat television maybe radio and
a lot of people didn't listen to radio
just put a tape in their car yeah and
you know me maybe you when you were a
kid you listen to some local news but
not very often so you wouldn't know if
there was something in your
area that was going down that was going
on like this it'd have to be pretty
widespread before all you would find out
about it yeah people were kind of
trusting I think from looking back well
I'm like I said to this guy seemed to
target people in in lots of different
states and as I said a lot of the people
that he targeted were in you know fast
food restaurants or grocery stores where
even the managers might be like really
young might be you know afraid of losing
their jobs afraid of authority like
they're you know if they really think
that's a cop because apparently
according to a lot of the people that
they interviewed like you know that had
fallen for the scam the guy sounded very
convincing he sounded like he knew what
he was talking about he was very
authoritative you know so I can see and
plus another thing too is that you have
to imagine that the ones that we're
hearing about are the ones that worked
right you know how many times didn't
call somebody in everybody's like [ __ ]
you dude and then just like hung up
which is what we had obscene phone calls
yeah head prank phone calls whew yeah we
knew about those but this is a whole
nother thing you know I mean uh usually
an obscene or a prank phone calls pretty
obvious yeah you know you knew within a
few seconds that something was wrong
with the damn call right and I could
just remember what it was like back in
those times you know especially when you
were young you weren't even really sure
how certain systems worked like how
corporate systems worked yeah if you
worked for that company
you weren't fully aware of like what was
happening outside of say like your
branch well yeah you know I mean you
wouldn't know especially if you were
kind of like a low-level position here
or something like that why the [ __ ]
would you know and you're just going
there to get it back man yeah I worked
at Denny's and I worked at Shoney's I
knew how that restaurant worked
kind of yeah but not nothing outside
that restaurant I didn't know how
Denny's corporation work yeah the
corporate structure you were here think
about it so somebody called and they
sounded like they knew there was I knew
I had me oh well maybe he's true yeah
yeah and I could so I can see how a lot
of people fell for it like I said in
hindsight you can be like oh you dummy
it's like obviously you should have done
with it with this guy on the phone told
you to do but I don't know man I think a
lot of people might have fallen for it
that maybe didn't think they would fall
or you know what I mean because if
especially if he didn't know about it
ahead of time if someone was just
calling up so I really hesitate to call
any of the people and yeah into the
details there was a certain amount of
sexual fetish involved with this and
being pre-internet yeah so many people
maybe not really didn't really know much
about sexual fetishes outside real what
they saw yes it wouldn't occur to that
neighbor an image this is some kind of
like a power fetish day yeah you know
it's not the average person you know
straight-laced just looking blue collar
middle of nowhere person working at damn
McDonald's they wouldn't even know there
was anything like a fetish scene yeah
especially like a weird specifically
yeah and I think that's what is really
good because the thing about it had to
be sexual if this was the same guy doing
this which I suspect that it was he
wasn't in most of the states that he
called the restaurant so he wasn't
watching I'm enough no this is phone
fantasy it was just like free phone sex
like well not free because I guess he
had to pay the longest it's like a phone
sex where no sex is happening no he
would buy phone cards that's what I was
thinking of yeah so he see out of buy
phone cards but I'm like why you just
call a phone sex line because really it
wasn't anything sexual really happening
not off in this in a certain way other
than taking people's clothes off it was
power oriented well there wasn't that
one that that is trunk well he well
we'll get to that a minute yeah I don't
think that was super obvious to the guy
who was doing it until he was already
knee-deep in it yeah he realized oh [ __ ]
yeah this guy can't work for the company
I think that's how it eventually but it
was too late mmm-hmm he was doing it
yeah alright okay we're gonna get to
yeah so as I said so which I was just
talking about some of the like I said
there were 70 of these [ __ ] things
not all of them were as bad some of them
stopped like pretty quickly but um you
know yes so there was this one where you
know a manager at McDonald's like strip
naked in front of a customer because
they said that he was a sexual predator
and she was supposed to serve as the
bait hmm
yeah so now there was another one that
happened in early 2003
and this happened at an Applebee's and
the guy called the Applebee's and he
said that he was a regional manager for
the restaurant and he said that one of
the waitresses was had either stolen
something or had drugs on her or
something
and he told the assistant manager that
she had to take her into the bathroom
and do a strip search which she did yeah
for an hour and a half yeah so you can
imagine how that yeah this is in an area
this is in an era when you know the
legality of such a thing might not be
real you know I mean you weren't really
sure what if that was legal or not like
can a company representative tell you
damn strips rotate it is not is not
legal all right
and it wasn't then and it was in it was
in the employee handbooks
yeah and [ __ ] like that or the managers
handbooks because that was one like in
the later incident that was one thing
that McDonald's was yeah you know
arguing in their counter lawsuit yeah
they probably didn't read it or
forgotten it I don't think I'm like I
said these were damn like I said it was
it was a low information era he's like
well the manager told me to do it it
must be legal yeah that was kind of okay
yeah I guess it's okay yeah man said I
could so about a month after that one at
the Applebee's there was another one
this one happened at a McDonald's in
Hinesville Georgia now this guy the guy
called said he was a cop and he said
that he was with the director of
operations for McDonald's like upper
management and he told the same thing
he's like um there's this girl she's
your female employee she has drugs you
take her into the bathroom strip-search
her and also a male employee was brought
in who did guess what a body cavity
search looking for the drugs yeah which
means he's putting his fingers up in
there yeah like up in her badge or
there's no but there's the word of Thank
You woody thinking Christ that's sexual
assault yeah yeah what you would think
that the purse
obeying this you would think that he it
wouldn't dawn on him that this was some
kind of sexual pervert on the other end
of the line you know asking him to do it
because the average person would be like
well what does he gain from it if it's
right sexual cuz they're [ __ ] I even
here he's not here I'm here he's on the
phone doc I said they didn't understand
fetishes and how these sex went well
[ __ ] were I guess not just him just
his imagination was enough yeah get him
off you know I mean he was you know
imagining that it was happening by his
command I guess some kinky [ __ ] doesn't
I mean this is like a very weirdly
specific fetish that's why I think this
is like one guy that was doing this yeah
it sounds like one weirdo here so this
poor girl yeah who works at [ __ ]
McDonald's in [ __ ] ass [ __ ] Georgia
it goes to work one day some idiot calls
and says she has drugs and then suddenly
some other dude that works in McComb oh
wow in his hand up her Bob's up her man
trying to find the can you [ __ ]
imagine I don't think I would ever gonna
do that but yes so now McDonald's
actually did get taken to court over
this so there was like a little bit of a
steak now the interesting thing about it
though is that like when the later more
famous what happened that the movie was
based on that was one of the basis of
the basis rather of the ensuing lawsuits
of which there were several
understandably was that McDonald's had
dealt with this exact same scam before
and didn't warn any of their other
regional managers about it or didn't
like say anything about it you know what
I mean
hmm so that was like one of the bait is
one of the bases that a lot of the
people later used to sue I can see why
they didn't say anything though in a
certain way but that's really something
that you need to particularly because
they wouldn't want to create copycats I
think it's part of it yeah well I mean
that's kind of like a gray area though
okay maybe they thought that it was just
so rare that it would never happen it
would never happen ever worry about that
you want to panic anybody they didn't
want to look bad in front of the
employees yeah
by that god yes well yeah obviously it
had to be something like that because it
makes it look makes them look like they
don't have their [ __ ] together right
it's just something like chode can call
up and I'm saying whatever I also think
maybe that they didn't want a situation
where you could have four or five custom
four or five employees collude yeah fake
that that happened in order to get a
settlement now the company right oh yeah
I didn't think of that yeah you know
time I still though I don't know it just
seems like something that should
probably be addressed at the manager was
especially because I mean there were
other restaurants and other grocery
stores targeted but McDonald's was the
most common target for whatever reason
I'm not sure why that is easily
controlled people maybe me I don't
really know or that was just working
maybe the dude just hated McDonald's and
he just like particularly didn't like
McDonald I don't know I just felt
comfortable calling maybe that's what it
was I don't know dealt with him so many
times yeah
so there was another one in July 2003
which was actually in Panama City
Florida this was actually any winn-dixie
store which is a grocery store in case
because I know other parts of the
country don't have winn-dixie
yeah so it's a grocery store now he's
the same thing he was a store manager at
the winn-dixie he got a phone call from
a guy who said that he was a police
officer the guy described a female
employee vaguely and then the manager
was like oh you mean such-and-such and
he was like yeah yeah that's her
so he the caller then requested that
this girl be taken into an office and
strip-searched so they made her take off
all our clothes and made her pose in
various ways I'm not sure what ways
they're talking about but I can imagine
so this actually was cut short because
one of the other managers came in the
office and was like what the [ __ ] is
going on in here so then the guy hung up
now there was another one in March of
2004 and this happened in Fountain Hills
Arizona this was at a Taco Bell and the
same kind of thing happened man called
claimed to be a police officer and
subjected to one of the female employees
to a strip search now the most famous
case of all of these different phone
scams like I said of which there were
about 70 that they have on record was
the one that happened in Mount
Washington Kentucky and this is the one
that the film compliance was based on
this happened on April 9th 2004 and this
was also a McDonald's now the assistant
manager whose name was Donna summers not
that one
that's just Donna Summer that wasn't
without an S on the end this is Donna
summers totally different this is a
white person and and not a awesome
singer or anything like that as far as I
know so she's the assistant manager she
gets a phone call from this guy who says
that he's a cop and he calls himself
officer Scott now he gives her kind of
like this vague description though it's
like this little bitty slight blonde
girl who was like working the front
counter or something she like one of the
customers was in here and accused her of
stealing something so Donna summers
helpfully goes oh you must mean Louise
who was Louise Ogburn who worked at the
restaurant I believe she was only 17 at
the time so she was working at the time
so the cop officer Scott quote/unquote
he says okay well Louise has to be
searched at the restaurant because we
can't like the cops are busy and like
this is a really minor matter so you
guys will have to do it there because we
don't have time for this [ __ ] even
though we had time to call you and like
say but you know whatever so it's like
we don't have any cops hard to do it so
you have to do so so she takes Louise
into the office and tells her to take
off all her clothes then she tell then
the guy tells Donna the assistant
manager okay we'll take all her clothes
and put them in a bag and lock them in
your car in the parking lot so Donna did
that so then she gives Louise an apron
because Louise is sitting there in the
[ __ ] McDonald's office naked so they
gave her an apron to cover herself up
now there was another girl that worked
there named Kim Dockery she was also an
assistant manager she was also present
and she was supposed to be there
according to this dude that was calling
like she's supposed to be like another
witness to the search he's got him all
deputized that's exactly what he was
doing right he's molesting women by
remote control yeah that's exactly what
it is
remote control male role in the show
yeah that's another t-shirt right there
yeah just like a certain brand of
[ __ ] we temp we have so many shirts
wait you guys so Kim Dockery she was
only there for about an hour and then
she had to leave either because her
shift was over she had other [ __ ] to do
or whatever at this point Donna told the
guy on the phone that you know I'm
actually at work and I should actually
be working you know like at the front
counter like so yeah
so the guy calling says to Donna oh well
then you need somebody that you trust to
come in and like watch this girl until
we can get out there and like do
whatever it is we need to do so she
tried to at first she tries to bring in
this other guy who was named Jason
Bradley he also worked there he was a
cook um so she's like okay well you need
to go in there and watch Louise and so
he goes in there for a little while
she's the poor little Louise is sitting
there with the apron on and the caller
says to Jason
okay well now have her take the apron
off and describe her to me
at which point Jason's like no yeah he
did he didn't want to do it
he didn't call the cops or anything like
that but he just said no I'm not doing
that
so then the caller is like okay well he
gets back with Donna and he's like
alright well that guy's not cooperating
so find somebody else that you trust you
know too so we can get this ball rolling
or whatever it was that he said so at
this point
Donna's Donna summers cuz that just
makes me laugh at her that her name is
that yeah then she calls up her fiance
who's name was Walter Knicks jr. who
didn't work there he like worked some I
don't know what the [ __ ] he did but he
worked somewhere else so she calls him
up and says hey are you doing anything
he need to watch this teenage girl who
I'm supposedly holding like for the cops
because she stole some [ __ ] so you need
to come here and like watch her and like
help me out or whatever yeah so he
[ __ ] turns up
now he comes in there and gets on the
phone with this jackhole on the phone
that says he's a police officer
and he talks to this dude for two hours
and does exactly what this dude on the
phone tells him to do for two hours
these included okay so they ask Walter
they're like okay we'll take off her
apron and make her dance yeah she's like
what a 60 year old girl she was 17 yeah
make her do jumping jacks yeah
while she's naked yeah in this little
[ __ ] office yeah um then he said make
her put her fingers in her vagina and
show it to you Dan
so that was part of the quote unquote
and she is doing it yeah well she she
said she was scared to death
she didn't as she thought that was
really a cop and that she was gonna get
in trouble
she might have also been afraid she was
gonna lose her job I don't know um so
then he said I got a I got a suspicion
that this dude was his name Walter
Walter I think Walter knew something I
think he was thinking like oh well this
guy's telling me on the phone that I can
do this they're all believe in it he's
gonna play along I kind of feel like
that too but you know so how old was he
I don't know because I saw pictures of
him from Courtney looked kind of old
yeah he's like a middle-aged yeah this
is the guy that I saw in the video kind
of heavyset middle-aged yeah yeah yeah
that dude was about 40 I think at least
yeah and I think he knew better
yeah I find a DJ later I think he did I
think he knew it was some kind of hoax
but everybody else was believing it so
he was going along and boy they get to
see a 17 year old girl jump I'm down do
all this [ __ ] and various other things
yeah because I think he was asking for
descriptions of it what yeah yeah yeah
he knew um yes should have been locked
up uh he was yokai spoiler alert not for
very long but right yeah so so she had
to she had to like put her fingers in
her vagina and just showing that
uh then she had to sit on the guy's lap
and kiss him yeah see you would know she
said no I don't want to do that and then
the caller was like well now you have to
spank her until she says that she will
and the guys [ __ ] does it could you
believe it at this point that's what I
mean I'm willing to give some of the
people in this latitude yeah but once it
gets to that point you know goddamn well
that the this is some sketchy [ __ ] yeah
even back in 94 you would know that that
was some [ __ ] well this was like
2004 2004 this - okay so I thought was
the one that was in 94 yeah oh yeah oh
yeah you would definitely know about
2004 yeah definitely and especially an
older guy yeah you know what I mean it's
like you'd think you would know better
yeah by that time you definitely would
know so yeah so this girl and then so
she gets spanked then the caller's like
we'll give her the phone and then he
starts yelling at her like you know you
better do what this guy tells you to do
or you're gonna get like in even worse
trouble and all this other kind of crap
so the one that I saw the videos from I
don't think was this 2004 bird I think I
saw the one from the 90s because I
remember this [ __ ] going on when I was
in the Army and I think I might have
just gotten out of the army when I saw
the videos so am i right on that one oh
it was a black-and-white security film
what kind of a heavyset guy know the
ones from this were in color okay so I
know I saw what are the older ones then
yeah they're platinum on television it
wasn't it wasn't explicit you know I
mean well yeah you couldn't see anything
in this one right here I mean they you
could see like you knew she was naked
but they like blurred it out okay well
they they were showing some of the
footage of this on that on the news yeah
of these of these calls yeah I don't
know if it was dead what couldn't bend
this one 2004 no yeah this was 2004 the
one that I saw was during the 90s yeah
well like I said that there there were a
lot like that like I said they started
in 92 there weren't really there were a
couple in 92 that were kind of note
but then there weren't really any more
notable ones until like 2003 or
somewhere around there but I think they
were going on like all that time yeah
there was that one guy doing it I'm John
Beck III think it was too because like I
said that is a very very specific kind
of thing and we'll kind of get into that
a minute so this poor little girl has
been sitting here naked having to do all
this creepy [ __ ] she gets spanked all
this other kind of crap she's been in
this office for two and a half hours
with this [ __ ] dude sitting there
like on the phone now the guy in the
phone says she has to give this Walter
guy a [ __ ]
he had a Howard why would the cops ask
you to do that right see that's what I
mean I think like I said I'm willing to
give some of the victims some latitude
like as long as the [ __ ] wasn't too
outrageous but the second some cop
called it what it says to you on the
phone oh well your old girl has to give
you a [ __ ] now yeah yeah yeah there's
no plausible denied there is no there's
no conceivable reason that a cop would
ask you to do that
a cop might ask you to give them a
[ __ ] but not some other dude that
they can't even say so you know what I
mean so yeah so I kind of feel like this
guy was like oh well the cop said I
could yeah I kind of feel like that
decision did she do it apparently yes
well I you know like I said she seemed
like a sweet little girl like I saw her
on the thing and she she was like super
terrified and she thought she was gonna
get in trouble and um you know and I
don't and I just think she'd been
sitting there for so long and I don't
think she liked me but if she thought
she was gonna go to jail that was her
way to get out she did okay I think she
was good she said no later on okay so he
had her because the cop like threatened
her said you're gonna get in worse
trouble if you don't do what I say and
you don't do what this guy says she
didn't know she was 17 you know what I
mean like I said if there's any fault
one obviously the dude on the phone and
this other [ __ ] showed that listen to
everything that he said oh that's you
shouldn't know exactly like I said so
yeah so she does that [ __ ] now keep in
mind that Donna summers the assistant
manager this is her fiance Yeah right
now she has to keep coming back into the
office periodically because she's still
working she's still on her shift now
when she comes back in the office then
the caller says okay well she's coming
back in you know if she comes back in
just like put the apron back on the girl
and like act like nothing happened which
is what she did so after all this um you
know with when the manager keeps coming
back in that finally Walter next starts
saying oh I started feeling bad about
I'm like oh just now you started feeling
bad about it okay
you know what I mean so the caller says
okay well you can leave now but Donna
has to find somebody else to take your
place I mean this has been going on for
like hours and hours and hours yeah like
this dude that's calling it's like
doesn't have anything better to do I
guess not so he's just like being on the
phone with the McDonald's for five hours
getting them like I got a story i got a
story
I got started okay I love this because
I'm you know I'm not go off the rails
every now and never I got a kind of
relate a story is related to this okay
all right remember and Matt found
poltergeist cases talk about Big Jim
Jimmy he was one to suck he was the one
that's sitting on the table or sitting
on the table sitting on the damn couch
mm-hmm when the Hot Wheels moves you
know he'd hidden here's one that ran yes
from the poltergeist well that was Reds
buddy yeah time right and he was a chef
that worked at round Table Pizza yeah
back in the 80s you know and he was
stana dude must have weighed 250 pounds
couldn't bend more like 300 pounds do a
second like you know morbidly obese yeah
okay
he was cool dude though ma'am just go
there and he'd make free pizza for us
and [ __ ] that's always a plus yeah he
was in there working nights one night
and it was just him and one waitress and
she was this fine looking waitress I
remember okay
I remember her name but I remember her
she was probably about 20 maybe younger
yeah well three guys came in there and
robbed the place pistols with a pistol
mm-hmm and cleared the place out well
they didn't rape that girl but what they
did was is they put in a god of Jimmy
and made
her made him to have sex with her in the
back all right
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] you never told me that
yeah what wasn't didn't really come up
but he didn't do it he couldn't do it
all right and they were just a trim we
could do couldn't get up and he was so
fat you know what I mean you just but
they were just laughing their asses off
they laugh and just ran out with the
money yeah the [ __ ] is the matter with
people they didn't want I guess they
didn't want to leave they didn't want to
leave behind any evidence you know that
means they just wanted I guess I have
what they thought was fun before they
fled the scene they were closing when
you had the place came it was out in
California that's [ __ ] up yeah
and they pointed a gun at him told him
to [ __ ] a Draper and he she was taking
her clothes off he took his clothes off
they did and he started to like Tim like
he was doing it they just started
laughing so hard than they ran yeah now
she quit of course you know I mean you I
don't think you can charge a guy for
that well no because he was I mean it
wasn't his fault and it was always
afraid that he was gonna get killed
yeah right he couldn't have sex with her
yeah looking he wasn't he wasn't in the
mood you know I got dude pointing guns
at you and [ __ ] you know I mean yeah
that might like that - is that
performance anxiety and they just I
guess the sight of it they just started
they just thought it was so funny they
just thought that [ __ ] was hilarious and
then they ran ran out with all the money
and she called it [ __ ] up she quit me
he kept MIT he kept working there though
I don't blame her for getting yeah I
would quit moving there is [ __ ] bonds
of all like the next days Jeannie come
back [ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] can you
imagine so yeah so this poor girl has
done all this kind of crap and the
caller says to Walter Nicks who as I
said is only just now starting to get
uncomfortable with the whole situation
or said he claimed the caller says okay
but you have to find somebody else to
replace you now Walter finally left the
restaurant reportedly as soon as he left
and they showed this in the movie
compliance as well that as soon as he
he was in his car and he called a friend
of his and said quote I have done
something terribly bad yeah you did yeah
shoulda stopped that [ __ ] so after he
left um Donna summers now as I said no
Donna summers she didn't know about the
oral sex and the vagina flashing and all
that other stuff I mean because she had
been out front working it so she didn't
know about that at the time so she's
looking around for someone to take
Walters place cuz this douche is still
on the phone and like still saying I
need somebody else there to watch her
and blah blah blah and she's like look
I'm busy I'm working at the front desk
so then she goes to she sees this guy
named Thomas Sims now he was actually he
worked there as the maintenance man but
he wasn't on shift at that time he had
just come in to like get an ice cream
cone or something like that and so she
says to him hey can you come in the back
office and like watch this girl and told
him the whole story and everything like
that now he goes back there and starts
talking to the dude on the phone but
this guy immediately was like no he's
like who the [ __ ] are you I don't know
what the [ __ ] is going on so he
immediately knew something sketchy was
up and he just refused he's like I'm not
[ __ ] doing it now the fact of him
doing that maidana think oh [ __ ] maybe
this is all a bunch of [ __ ] so
finally finally she calls like a higher
level manager at McDonald's because the
the guy that claimed to be a cop on the
phone he had said a couple times oh I've
been in contact with you know your
regional manager or whatever it is and
he says do this that and the other thing
so she calls the regional manager and
that guy says I don't know what you're
talking about I've been asleep all day
you know or whatever I've been talking
about coppers I don't even know what the
[ __ ] you're talking about
so finally she realizes that this whole
[ __ ] thing has been a fraud now what
they managed to do one quick thinking
employee remember back in the back in
the early 2000s when somebody called and
then they hung up
you could star-69 and it would like go
back call them back back yeah so one
employee my tech ship yes so like as
soon as they as soon as that guy
hung up one of the employees said oh we
have to like before another call comes
in we have to star 69 M so we can figure
out what his phone number was so they
star 69 him and they got the phone
number of his telephone
so was it a phone or was it it was a
calling card thing it ended up being a
calling card um you know yeah so
whatever how high-tech remember how
high-tech [ __ ] caller ID used to seem
uh-huh back in those days it was for you
kids that don't know how good you have
it we come from a time where to if you
want to know who it was he had to damn
answer the phone and it was too late yes
that's the [ __ ] sucks man well so they
we had they ended up offering this
service called caller ID it was this
little tiny box you'd have next to your
phone and you could see what a phone
number it was calling you which they do
on cell phones them they didn't used to
it back in those days that was a big
[ __ ] it was a big [ __ ] and it was
Nettie I don't think I ever showed the
name I don't think they didn't have
never showed any name it was just a
number I think um now I can't remember I
don't think it had any names no I think
it did because I think we had one that
had it up so you I think you could get
different versions all right and he
didn't want to answer you just let that
[ __ ] ring which is what I do myself I
don't know it's like I know that's not
answer mine right because I made it pay
extra I think you paid an extra $20 a
month for you did it was very expensive
yeah we had it for a little while but
this is Tony
like I said I couldn't go back to that
budget so all right so at this point the
caller has hung up
they've star 69 they got his phone
number uh Donna summers is freaking out
because she can't believe she [ __ ]
fell for this [ __ ]
she is like just falling over herself
apologizing this poor little [ __ ]
girl Louise who has been stuck in this
[ __ ] office naked for three and a
half hours and [ __ ] McDonald's
getting sexually assaulted so you know
so at that point they called the real
police they arrested Walter Nicks on a
charge of sexual assault and then
started investigating to see if they
could find who had made the the phone
call
now as it turned out there was a
surveillance camera in the offices there
are in most fast food restaurant offices
Donna summers watched this
surveillance tape later that night and
saw her fiance doing all that [ __ ] to
that little girl
yeah and not surprisingly broke their
engagement right she didn't kill him
which is what I would have done now yeah
he did no come on that's what I mean
after a certain point yeah like I said
I'm willing to give the victims a lot of
leeway in this because you have somebody
calls it as long as it sounds like a
reasonable request but once a grown man
once he gets into jumping jacks and hey
have her give you a [ __ ] at that
point is it
what possible thing could you be
investigating with that come only thing
the only thing that I could the only
thing that I can make of that situation
somehow that dude on the phone eased
that guy into it so slowly he that was
too late I think that's an issue kind of
got resolved and he didn't want to admit
to himself and to others that he'd been
taken I think that happens a lot and I
think that a lot of they say more when
if she would hit make her blow you come
on man that's what I mean that seems
like it would be come on more but as I
said like you said I think that's why
that guy was so good at this is because
some of the early stuff that he said
sounded kind of reasonable and they said
he sounded kind of like a cop and he
sounded like he knew what he was talking
about and then he just gradually
gradually like ramped it up until like
you said you got to a point where you're
doing this stupid [ __ ] because she
didn't want to admit that you've been
fooled this yet time like for two hours
or however long you're on the phone with
this douche because gotta be some kind
of point where the spell is broken
yeah boom you know I mean we're not I
know yeah and it's interesting that it
took you know this other guy this
maintenance man at the McDonald's who
was in there that Donna summers asked
like to come in like that I talked to
the guy on the phone for like two
seconds was like [ __ ] E I'm not doing
that and that's what it took for Donna
to finally like wake up and be like oh
maybe this whole thing has been a scam
that's because he that guy wasn't warmed
up he didn't yeah you'd only just come
in yeah
so when he got on the phone he was going
from zero to 90 in a second
he hadn't been eased into the car right
yeah because like I said so after that
like I said Walter Nix got arrested and
they started trying to find out where
the calls had come from now when the
cops like started doing like search on
the internet and stuff they discovered
that there have been several thing you
know many many other incidents of this
same type of thing occurring over a
bunch of other states so they they
contacted a bunch of other you know
police departments in other areas where
that had happened and you know we're
trying to coordinate with that now at
first they were thinking because this
guy was clearly a pervert they thought
that he was calling from a pay phone
where he could see because apparently
the police station was really close to
that particular McDonald's so they
thought that he was calling from a pay
phone where you could see both of them
because they thought that he'd get his
jollies on light unlike seeing the
people understand the power of
imagination right I guess not
yeah but as it turned out the dude and
like I said this McDonald's was in
[ __ ] Kentucky the dude was calling
from Panama City Florida yeah so Florida
man yep he's a Florida man sorry guys
yeah yeah in Florida right now I'm
Florida woman yeah yeah so yeah so he
was calling for Panama City Florida the
call was made with an AT&T phone card
and that most of these cards were
purchased at Walmart so they went to the
Panama City Walmart they you know got
all of the subpoenaed all there you know
cameras and [ __ ] like that's they're
trying to find this [ __ ] dude now
they also found out that that there had
been like some other scams like similar
scams going on in the Boston area and
they had pictures of the dudes back or
something like that and then some of the
Walmart's had pictures of kind of his
front so they were able they weren't
super clear but they were able to get um
you know like kind of a composite sketch
of what he looked like
so they found the guy that bought the
phone cards in the Walmart in Panama
City Florida was wearing a correctional
officers uniform from a private security
firm called the Corrections Corporation
of America so they think that this was
the guy that did it because the same
dude that they saw on the Panama City
Walmart tapes was the same guy that they
saw in the Massachusetts Walmart
purchasing a phone card right around the
same time that there was a similar scam
happening and that was I sent my water
you would do yeah and when they found so
this guy that they found his name was
David R Stewart
they found him through like they they
narrowed it down and then they went you
know to the Corrections Corporation of
America and went through all their
personnel records reservoir and they
found yeah he was a married guy he had
five kids so he got arrested now they
asked him if he had ever purchased a
phone card and he said no but when they
searched his house they found several
phone cards and found by tracking the
numbers or whatever that they had been
used to call at least nine restaurants
in the previous year including a Burger
King in Idaho Falls Idaho and they were
able to determine that that was the same
they called the manager there and he
said yeah we did get a call on that deal
like a scam call him that day where they
attempted to get somebody to strip naked
or whatever soon yep so they also um
found when they Florida stripe it looks
like I said sorry guys yeah just for
people that maybe you are in the United
States you can't really you know Florida
comes up a lot but you have to
understand that like Florida Florida
would be like the equivalent of a
European country in a certain way you
know it's a vast state with its very
large a lot of different kind of people
there's this British guy uh he's on
YouTube called calls himself uh sargon
of akkad he was here recently he took
his family to Disney World
evidently British people go to Disney
World quite a bit but he did a video
looking out his hotel
or yeah he's out on the balcony and he
was just blown away by Florida how hot
it is said it was like being covered in
wet blankets and that's exactly what
it's like outside accurate and then he
was just looking out over the damn swamp
around Disneyworld
in that area area and it does I guess if
you're not used to it if you come from a
place that's very urbanized you know
like he was I don't know exactly where a
boy is from in England but you know I
guess it would be mind-blowing to see
this state from you know from the ground
I guess you know but it's for sure
swampy yeah we just take it for granted
it's Dagobah danca but well I don't know
is that where Disney World is now I mean
until the early 70s that was a swamp
just swamp yeah
there was nothing there yeah it's got
Islands out there with abandoned
amusement parks on it and everything
mm-hmm yeah it's a trip it's big it's
the state is big about how big would it
be is about size France I don't know
it's hard to tell because it's like it's
long yeah you know what I mean so young
and skinny yeah it's only about 150
miles across yeah
really long and very diverse the
Panhandle is more like Mississippi but
like a swamp version in Mississippi
super rednecky yeah and then when you go
down to the very south it's basically
kind of like Cuba its Cuba and like
super rich white people yeah and with a
skyline just built on cocaine you know
that goes back to that Miami Vice era
yeah basically all the all the damn big
housing developments and everything was
all cocaine money just that particular
town is mafia controlled basically they
were the ones that built it yeah yeah
it's but Warren or Lando you know
Orlando's like the new Hollywood really
well because like I said until Disney
owns everything until the early 70s
there wasn't much of anything here so
pretty much everything is fairly new
like in the last 30 40 years yeah and
everybody we know works in some way for
Disney a lot of people a lot of people
it's a very large employer yeah you know
so
and now that Disney Owens [ __ ] all
the [ __ ] basically owns all the
Hollywood they don't everything now you
know all the [ __ ] big franchises they
own Star Wars and predator and alien and
everything they're gonna start making
those so this is the new Hollywood and
it does remind me of the way California
was when I was a kid yeah it does this
reminds me of Southern California but a
tropical version of it yeah yeah yeah so
they're searching this dude's house and
like I said they found all these [ __ ]
you know phone cars phone carts that
corresponded to like other similar scam
calls that had taken place in other
parts of the country they also found a
[ __ ] ton of applications for jobs in the
police department
whole a bunch of magazines about police
like police work and stuff like that
police style uniforms guns holsters so
he was another cop groupie yes that's
why he was so convincing yeah cuz he
he'd studied oh because he had studied
all up on it talk like he was already a
prison guard so he you know was used to
that culture
mhm so he could he had the confidence to
pull pull off being a cop to civilians
yeah which like I said that's why his
scam worked so many times now he was
actually as I said he lived in Florida
but they extradited him to Kentucky
about this particular case because they
thought that they could get him on
various charges among them impersonating
a police officer
obviously solicitation of sodomy and
various other and various other things
now if he had been convicted he would
have gotten 15 years in prison however
he was sadly acquitted yeah because they
they yeah they felt like they didn't
have enough evidence even though they
found all the phone cards and all the
other kind of [ __ ] to this whatever so
they did say though that once he was
arrested even though and put on trial
even though he was later acquitted no
more of those calls were reported after
that time which makes me think that they
were all him yeah you know what I mean
oh it was him yeah it's I mean you know
allegedly I guess we could say because
he did get acquitted but I was also I
still think there's too
too many too many connected dots right
there yeah that just seems like too
perfect maybe what something wouldn't
stick in court but you pretty much know
that zip yeah and I'd suspect they're
probably law enforcement thought that as
well a rope really pissed that he got
off with it but he did apparently stop
or at least none of those similar kind
of things have been reported afterwards
on the up side no one was hurt or killed
physically other than just you know
molesting girls by damn remote control
which is bad but at least not talking
about a serial killer jury no that's
like something serial killer would think
about yes maybe that's what I need
honestly real killers start off with
[ __ ] like this in peeping toms stuff and
I was thinking about that when I was
reading about these [ __ ] ass clowns
of prank net I was thinking about that
because I was like you know what these
guys are clearly not as bad as serial
killers but it's the same same type of
[ __ ] it's just a matter of degree yeah a
lot of them's kind of start off at this
kind of [ __ ] yeah because it's basically
treating another person as an object for
your own amusement or edification and
that is a very similar I mean that is a
very dangerous road to go down
most serial killers start off with like
scam [ __ ] like this and peeping tom
stuff and you know they start off with
little little stuff yeah now some of
them go on to be serial killers now most
these people that do scam [ __ ] like the
most of them don't go on to be serial
killers yeah but this is something that
they have in common with serial killers
and I was thinking about that exact
thing like I said obviously they're not
as bad but it's a matter of degree and
matters it's on the same path yeah the
ends and snapping stones because it's
basically a type of sociopathy is what
it is
well it's a big fantasy life take it
over yeah like who [ __ ] sits around
fantasizes about this [ __ ] and he can't
even see it yeah which is really very
strange to say are you fantasizing about
this [ __ ] you mean no but it would be
better and you can see it but it's Lepik
rehear but still and then you do it
right and that's not enough you gotta do
it again yeah do it again and then you
do it again he did it so you've got some
issues if you can't work this this kink
out of your system you know talking
about his wife now
it's like why your the phone all the
time are you talking there's people into
some weird kinky [ __ ] you do you think
that [ __ ] once you do it you get it
out of your system now this month will
get worse
yeah you just kept on doing it I don't
really get serial killers because if
they have a weird fantasy right that
involves killing somebody why isn't it
immediately kind of like satisfied where
you know what that that was just fantasy
and it wasn't that good you know and I'm
doing anymore because I already did it
some reason no they're gonna do it again
because they always think if they do it
again that's what they're thinking
they're totally fixated totally fixated
and I guess it's a personality types
like some kind of an addictive
personality type well yeah they have to
keep like yeah getting a bigger rush out
of it there's nothing in my sexual drive
you know I'm thought about that
possesses me in that way yeah you don't
talk about nothing I mean it's yes
experience and I think that's for most
people hopefully yeah I'd be really
scared to go outside of my house if it
was have some strong ass feelings you
got to think about one aspect of
sexuality just over and over again I
just wonder like this it like I said
this particular guy it's just this
fascinated me so much because it's just
so weird
it's so weird and specific yeah how do
you even remote control think of that
how do you even think of that it's just
very much it's a power thing I guess but
like I said he's not even seeing it now
they people are obeying him yeah just
his words and he's hearing about it yeah
yeah and they're telling him about it
and and he's just getting off on that I
guess that's some weird [ __ ] obeying his
commands yeah that's why you wanted to
be a cop they got some dudes out there
that [ __ ] want power so badly they
good and I wonder why they wouldn't be
like him hmm that's weird dude yeah so
even though this douche got acquitted
they did go a little bit into like if
you go the Wikipedia page they go a
little bit into like the aftermath of
poor little Louise who was only [ __ ]
17 she had actually been planning on
going to the University of Louisville in
Kentucky she was going to be a big
pre-med Stu
but she ended up not wanting to do that
because she ended up having like a lot
of because they had a treat her for a
poetic stress disorder like after things
so she like had a lot of problems after
that she didn't actually end up getting
a fairly large settlement from
McDonald's um because at the court case
see McDonald's tried to say oh well you
guys shouldn't have fallen for it
Susan the Donna summers she shouldn't
have you know there's a thing right in
the handbook that says you know no strip
search there's no strip searches know
people that don't work there are not
allowed in the office she you know she
let her fiance in the office and [ __ ]
like that so she did [ __ ] to break the
law to orb like break their rules too
but in the end they did actually end up
getting like a little I think Louise
actually ended up getting 1.1 million
and I think I think Donna summers got
like 400 thousand or something like that
so they did both get a settlement and
McDonald's does actually have that
specific thing like in their handbooks
now and it's like in all their training
regimes and stuff because they kind of
got in trouble for not addressing it
because like I said it had happened at
other McDonald's stores prior to this
and even one of their like security like
they're high up security guys had like
said hey we should probably put this in
the training program or something like
that and the McDonald's like corporate
hadn't done it so they had been warned
about it and hadn't acted on it so that
was one of the things that kind of got
them in trouble later on so they
actually did have to pay out it wasn't a
huge settlement but they did actually
have to pay out some so as I said Walter
Nix the guy that you know the fiancee
that did all the [ __ ] to the girl he
actually pleaded guilty to sexual abuse
sexual misconduct and unlawful
imprisonment because he wouldn't allow
the girl to leave the office he got a
plea deal you know in exchange for his
testimony against David Stewart the
caller alleged caller now Walter Nix
ended up getting five years in prison
for sexual assault okay so he did time
so he did do time
because like I said that's obviously you
should have known
you should have known no one was there
like you know it wasn't a situation like
you're like the guy that your uncle knew
it's like no one had a gun to your head
there was no one there was Jude on the
phone telling you to do this [ __ ] yeah
and he should have known better
yeah they told him this get your clothes
off you get your clothes off too go
ahead get it get going yeah basically
yeah that's what I mean and in that case
yeah we talked about performance anxiety
well yeah he was Chinese like then they
started busting up laughing they didn't
they just ran that's [ __ ] up like yeah
this kind of shit's [ __ ] up yeah as I
said if you haven't seen the movie
compliance you should definitely check
it out it is a very it's actually a
really accurate portrayal of what
happened on the actual thing I have seen
interviews with Donna summers she
actually kind of did the rounds on talk
shows and stuff like that like after
this kind of hit the media and I mean
she looks like a very average like dumpy
middle-aged woman you know middle
manager type person and you know she's
like oh people ask me all the time it's
like Huckabee Saddam it's like how can
you fall for this and stuff like that
but she said you know you weren't on the
phone with this guy he was really
persuasive and she's like I wasn't the
only one that fell for it you know he
called like people all over the country
and friend and they fell for it too so
it's like yeah she's got a point there
was kind of dumb but it's like you know
what are you gonna do you got some
[ __ ] dude on the phone like telling
you but yeah check out the check out the
movie compliancy it's really good now I
also want to talk about like where are
we at time okay so we're already at one
hour [ __ ] this is gonna happen I got a
refill money okay so what we're gonna do
it's I want to take a break right now
and we come back I want to get into you
talking about prank net and we'll talk
about that we'll see how long that takes
and if we have time I'll just get a
little bit into like the Milgram
experiment stuff like that because it's
a little bit relevant to this type of
stuff it's like I said it's people had
obeying Authority and [ __ ] like that
that might not take that long to do but
I do when I get in this prank mad [ __ ]
because god these dudes are [ __ ] I
just wanted to like [ __ ] punch him
through the [ __ ] computer screen all
right so we're gonna take a break right
now and we'll be back in just a few
minutes
what you doing underneath there am fun
yeah I'd like your cold it's not a hole
what's he doing hey Spira normal
podcasts proudly presents the strange
realities conference strange realities
come join us for one day of
presentations on the paranormal of live
music and night featuring Tim the knob
the rise and fall of the Flat Earth
theory Joshua coach an alien hybrid Lord
Odom re pushing the limits of reality
what really happened Timothy Renner
Pennsylvania wild man and add it to the
lineup Marc Anthony Wyatt cordis legends
and UFO sighting Zach hunt presentation
of his book on the route
by a live recording of the
conspiratorial podcast more speakers and
music acts to be announced October 19
2019 si our nationís info at WWE at ease
conference comm $40 at the door 30 bucks
presale
[Music]
you love true crime I love true crime
and I've spent the last three years
compiling a series of the most
intriguing unsolved murders of the 20th
century it's called the faceless villain
and volume three is available now
featuring such fascinating cases as the
Caddy murders the carry baby's case the
Frog Boys the al-qasr murders and the
inokashira park dismemberment incident
the faithless villain volume three is an
involving exploration of unsolved slang
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999
pick up your copy and print or eBook
formats on Amazon or download the
audiobook version from audible.com and
get ready for a chilling journey through
modern crime history
all right we are back now you have you
refilled your drink kitchen never filled
a drink I didn't need to refill my drink
because I still have some
now speaking of douches on the phone as
I said when I was researching this strip
search phone call scam one of the links
from Wikipedia linked to this thing
called prank net which I had never heard
of thankfully and now I'm kind of sad
that I know what it is but so I so I
started researching that and I'm like
okay well I got to put this on the show
- because it's like pretty much real
lady cuz they were doing the same kind
of [ __ ] now this is not one guy this is
a bunch of guys that's a collective the
two kind of main head honchos of it or
whatever are Canadian but the other guys
are American there are also a couple of
women in there too although they're kind
of like on the fringes or whatever this
is basically okay what these [ __ ]
[ __ ] heels do is they will do a similar
thing you know with phone scans and
stuff and get people to do like really
destructive really dangerous things and
if they come out good they will put them
on YouTube is like hilarious
quote-unquote epic prank videos sounds
like the Jerky Boys you're the Jerky
Boys yeah I named the Jerky Boys yes
sounds like that back in the day well
and the thing about it too is that I you
know I never thought the Jerky Boys were
funny or there was a show on Comedy
Central called cranky acres which was
also very similar if they would do like
crank calls but then they would reenact
them like with puppets as far as I'm
back in the 90s but they as far as I can
remember like I said I never thought I
never thought like prank humor was like
particularly funny so I never like
watched that kind of [ __ ] I mean to me
it just seems like really [ __ ] like
an [ __ ] I shouldn't like mean
spirited so I never really watched it
but I feel like even the Jerky Boys and
[ __ ] like that they when they did prank
phone calls they weren't like hurting
anybody or destroying anything I mean
yeah it was annoying and stupid and
everything like that boys was all kind
of centered around impressing Howard
Stern if you ask me well yeah there was
a lot of that
as well it was funny in the day yeah you
listen to it now and it's very juvenile
I'm just saying I thought it was stupid
back then but yes maybe that's cuz I'm a
girl zone
oh no it's not really much definitely
male humour very good that's what I mean
is it's stupid some of that I like but
it's like I never liked price even back
in the old days remember [ __ ] candid
camera with a L'Enfant yeah or whatever
even that like I used to watch with my
grandma's stuff but even that like made
me uncover I'm like man that's me if I
can do that why would you do that I
think I don't know I just I I guess I
don't like pranks I don't like I think
you I think is the male sense of humor
especially maybe like the American male
sense of humor is it's kind of me it's
kind of like it is yeah just slightly
mean-spirited very different from say
like British humor no they're very
mean-spirited what's that
they're humor is very okay well it
wouldn't work more than ours more would
assume I thought I found that when I was
pretty assuming that I've seen all has
to be no it's all like very clever it's
almost kind of like two-faced but there
is a strain of it that's like that but
but you realize you can't do that in the
United States you get your ass beat or
shot you know that that's how a lot of
those shootings happened is because it's
because of something somebody said yeah
I mean so American sense of humors not
it's not what's good way to put it it's
not backhanded in that way it's more
in-your-face it's more obvious but like
I said having been over there like
having spent a lot of time over there to
me they seem much more forthright than
American does it okay yeah I'm just
talking about I'm just talking about by
the humor that I see in movies and stuff
oh don't go there yeah I want to go
there it's nice there I like it well
you've never been so I liked it over
there but yes I owe your but I didn't
know they're always found their humor
much more there they're like taking the
piss out of people that's like their
whole thing so we spend them I've always
found it much more violent you you can I
mean they'll say [ __ ] to your face
that an American well yeah yeah the
American would not you could do that too
with your friends you know if you trust
them but you can't take the piss out of
somebody you don't know here in the
United States you literally could get
shot honestly these prank net guys I'm
surprised they have not been shot right
right I think it was only because people
didn't know who they were
right but now they do because they've
all been doxxed so yeah so these [ __ ]
chodes um there's a bunch of them
there's kind of just like five or six
main miscreants but what they would do
like I said they would try to do like
these epic quote unquote that was like
their big thing these epic pranks they
wanted really good ones to put on
YouTube as far as I know most them are
still there like I actually searched
prank net on YouTube and it looks like
lots of their videos are still on there
I don't watch any I'm because I don't
want to give any of these [ __ ] ass
clowns any views but it doesn't appear
that they've been like banned or taken
down or anything like that so this
shit's still on there I don't know how
old it is like I said they're their
heyday was kind of like 2009 to 2011
when they were like causing all this
property damage and stuff so their whole
shtick their main guy went by the
pseudonym Dex he was named after Dexter
from the TV show obviously about the
serial killer what they would start
doing they started about in 2009 and Dex
was actually a big fan of the Jerky Boys
and of Crank Yankers and wanted
something like that was much bigger than
that thankfully he never realized that
dream but because he never really got
anywhere with this [ __ ]
other than everyone just thinking he was
a [ __ ] loser but so what they
initially started doing they wouldn't
use like regular phones they actually
started out using Skype because I guess
prior to 2009 skypes policies were a lot
more lenient and you could like you know
have kind of anonymous presence on there
but after they started pulling some of
their crap like Skype started
investigating them so then they moved to
pal talk which I guess was like a
competing you know like a competing
service but Paltalk also banned them
after they found out what they were up
to at what
point him and all his other little
minions gave they did like a do s attack
a denial-of-service attack on against
paltalk so they have subsequently moved
all their [ __ ] to a plate a thing called
Bey Lux which I've never heard of but I
guess it's like a Skype like service but
it's not based in the United States so I
guess like the same illegal restrictions
don't apply or whatever so some of the
[ __ ] that these [ __ ] did so February
2009 Dex who like I said he's the main
guy but he's not the only one he's like
a bunch of other ones to do this crap
for him and they also um when they do
the pranks they do them live online and
they have like a like a chat group like
a live chat so they'll have people in
the chat room like tell them hey do this
how you do that how you do the other
thing you know I mean so it's like a
group [ __ ]
there's no it's not like a huge group
they said the most that's ever been in
the chat room at the time was like 200
people but it's that type of thing so
February 2009 Dex calls up a KFC
restaurant in Manchester New Hampshire
now he said that he was a manager from
the corporate office and he told the
employees that they needed to douse the
building with fire suppression chemicals
and then that they had to go outside
into the parking lot take all their
clothes off and pee on each other
because the fire suppression chemicals
were caustic and by peeing on one
another the chemicals would be rendered
inert okay sounds good so he actually so
three girls actually did do it now this
no it was girls yeah so this prank he
actually did put on YouTube I don't know
if it's still there um but it was
initially the description of it was epic
cuz that's the big word that they use
all the time yeah they sound like
they're like five but they're actually
like in their 20s and one was like way
way bold enough to know better so yeah
it said like epic KFC prank call
greatest ever Dec successfully
successfully convinces the three
employees at undress fully nude outside
and urinate on each other yeah yeah now
after he did that successfully a few
months later he called the same KFC
store saying that he was an insurance
adjuster and then talked to the same
employees and got them to describe what
had happened to them over again now keep
in mind like I said that he's doing this
over a Skype like service you guys okay
at this point they had balls there but
that's not balls I was had a chance to
call him back that's just being a dick I
wouldn't have the guts to call it back
it's just like no I think I believe him
alone but you know what I mean so keep
in mind it's not just him doing is just
there's other people listening like on
the live chat like while this is going
on that's man I think you gotta have
gall to do that no I just think you have
to be a stupid-ass but how do you know
they're not bugging how do you know
they're not bugging the the restaurant I
know about these guys and this is
actually very funny to me and if you
want like go to The Smoking Gun website
just smoking with gun calm The Smoking
Gun or whatever it is and because
there's really funny write-ups cuz they
were the one that doxed all these
[ __ ] because they did an
investigation into it and the [ __ ] they
write about them is like so so funny
every single one of these douches that
they dogs is exactly like if you were
making fun of some like [ __ ] keyboard
warrior like fat lives in his mom's
basement and I can't get laid the every
single one of them is like that it was
it would be like a joke but there but
it's not so one of their next things
that they did happened on February 10th
which was only a few days after the
other one so Dex and then there was this
other guy who went under the name DT a
Mike they called a Best Western in
Shillington Pennsylvania and said that
they were both that they both worked at
the front desk now they told the people
in the room that there was a ruptured
gas line in the hotel and that they
needed to break the window of their
hotel room and throw the TV out
because they told them that the TV would
explode from the gas yeah that was what
they did they did that several times yes
so yeah they they got they did the same
thing with another Best Western on
February 19th that was in Santee
California they got they just called
random rooms that's what they would do
that they would either call the front
desk and ask for a random room or in the
case of Motel 6 I think you could just
call into the rooms without knowing
anybody's name like they don't let you
do that anymore right where you can just
call the front doesn't go hey give me
room 305 or whatever if you don't even
know who's in there
they don't let you do that anymore but
they did at the time so they would just
call a random room and say hey there's a
gas leak in here just you need to like
and throw the TV out the window so April
30th there was another member whose name
was rolling in the a so you can see what
level you're dealing with here oh they
just have like the stupidest it's like I
was just reading this and the smoking
gun right up with them is so funny
because the smoking gun is just like
they were just calling them like by all
these horrible names like this dough a
[ __ ] and it's like look he's
hiding behind his mommy and all this
other kind of stuff it's like it's
Larry's so okay so this was a rollin in
the a so called he calls a prisons
restaurant in Lafayette Louisiana saying
he's an official from the health
department
they picked this restaurant in
particular because this restaurant had
live video streaming of its dining area
like on its website and they wanted to
be able to like show the idiots who were
watching their prank call you know what
was happening in real time so basically
they called the manager of this hotel or
you know the person working at this or
at this restaurant and said that the
pork there was tainted with swine flu
and that they needed to close the
restaurant immediately and tell all of
the diners to leave damn so there were
75 people eating in the room and
everyone ended up leaving my food and it
was live on the website that's what I
mean it's like
like I said I'm not a big fan of like
prank type stuff in the best of
situations but these and these guys have
done some horrible [ __ ] and then like
later on when they got doxxed like you
find out like what some of their prior
convictions and [ __ ] were for so you'll
see May 27th Dex calls a Hampton Inn in
New York Nebraska and made one of the
employees set off the fire alarm
now then he called the front desk and
said that well if you called the fire
department then they'll find you
so you need to like so he gave them like
all these instructions to turn the alarm
off which obviously didn't do anything
or didn't mean anything he said oh you
have to go to this website like to turn
the alarm off it was a porn website then
he says okay well you have to break the
front windows of the hotel at which
point they got a truck driver who was
staying at the hotel and the index on
the phone gets this guy to bat to like
drive his semi-trailer truck into the
front of the hotel lobby and break the
front windows so after that happened
like Dex if he put it on Twitter I just
pulled off this is what I said I just
pulled off the most epic prank I had a
no-tell guests back his truck into the
hotel front window in the lobby and
break the window but then he later
deleted it because he thought he was
gonna get in trouble cuz like I said
these dudes their whole thing was like
oh we're like ghosts on the internet no
one will find us and they think they
could but they don't they did get fun of
course cuz they're ready everything
needs a trail of course it does yeah
they they cocky was their problem they
thought they were so clever and smarter
than everybody and they weren't June
2009 there was another one at a holiday
though these are some ambitious [ __ ]
pranksters well like I said very
apparently the dude that and I'll tell
you who's like it what is real cuz they
found out like what is real well his
alleged real identity is yeah later on
but apparently it's his he really wanted
to make this like a big [ __ ] deal just
like like I said just like cranky
like that he wanted to make it like this
humongous rush he's just trying to get
views so he was trying to like make me
crazier and crazier
he's trying to make money was there wait
I guess so alright because Mary sure no
you didn't have a [ __ ] job that's
been betting all kinds of [ __ ] you
know you're gonna be all these are all
prosecutable offenses that's what I'm
seeing so it's like some of these are
felonies yeah I don't know if you guys
knew that but yeah yeah you well and
also they thought they could get away
with it because the two top guys Dex and
his kind of second-in-command
they were both in Canada so they thought
that if as long as they kept calling
ones in the US oh no that might make it
worse that's what I mean it's like they
thought that they could get away like I
said they were like well one of them was
like he's like [ __ ] 25 or something
so he doesn't know [ __ ] so they thought
oval because we're too caught we're just
calling ones in the US and not in Canada
to anything to us there's all kinds of
weird laws of weird agreement
extradition agreement in Canada Canada
can extradite yeah I think Canada might
be I think Canada can extradite yeah
yeah now yeah
they won't further the death penalty
yeah but anything actually they totally
would sure so okay so this is June 2009
they call a Holiday Inn Express in
Conway Arkansas and again he says he's
from the company that installed the
hotel's fire sprinkler and he's like oh
well the system needs to be reset so you
need to pull the fire alarm so then he
tells the clerk that he's like okay so
once the alarm goes off he's like okay
well the spray the sprinklers will come
on unless you break all the windows so
they did the same prank in Gadsden
Alabama at a Comfort Suites
so they get them to break their own
windows and set off the fire sprinklers
which floods the which flooded the hotel
in some cases are caused like thousands
of dollars worth of water damage
something so simple you wouldn't think
of that yeah to call them and say we got
to check your firearm yeah that's some
weird [ __ ] yeah
yeah and like some of these it's like
some of the [ __ ] that they did likes
because sometimes they would call
to people's rooms and it'd be like 3:00
in the morning and then they'd say oh
there's a gas leak in the hotel so you
have to like get some towels wet and put
them under your dorm break your windows
like to get air it's like it's 3:00 in
the morning you're orient it's like I
can understand like why somebody would
be like oh whatever
oh I'm gonna die oh my god you know what
I mean so I could see how people would
fall for something like that you know
what I mean yeah even is redic I mean
the whole thing about like take your
clothes off and pee on each other I mean
that's a little more I kind of know how
this works
right but a lot of people don't yeah you
know what I mean so it almost sounds
like a reasonable thing right so okay so
in July of that year
another member I'm not sure which one it
was called a Hilton in our hometown of
Orlando Florida said there was a gas
leak and there was a family staying in a
particular room they called in this
particular room and they said that you
have to break the windows with the lid
off your toilet tank oh yes so that cost
$5,000 in damages the same month another
caller told two guests at a hotel that
spiders were going to infest their room
and same thing they got them to break
their hotel window with the lid of the
toilet tank there was also another one
on July 5th two of the guys called an
Arby's in Baytown which I think is in
maybe Texas but that's actually where
one of the dudes lived they found out
later which stupid so he talks one of
the employees into triggering the fire
suppression system which caused 4600
dollars in damages he also tried to get
to get them to break the windows but
they would not now this one is super
gross and this I feel like this is
probably more serious than the other
[ __ ] so one of the dudes who was later
doxed as a dude his last name was Markel
I don't remember what his [ __ ] stupid
screen name was so he calls the Homewood
Suites in Lexington Lexington Kentucky
now what he did was he first called a
guest of the hotel and he told this
person that he was from the front desk
of the hotel and that one of the prior
who had stayed in the same room as him
had hepatitis C so he's like so I need a
urine sample to make sure you haven't
contracted it I think that's what he did
so he's like oh there's a doctor on site
you need to pee into a cup and bring it
down to the front desk so the guest like
pees into a cup brings it down to the
front desk now the same guy
Markel he now calls the front desk and
he says that he is an employee of
Martinelli's cider oh yeah she's a real
thing then he calls a different guy like
a different guest and tells her to come
down it's oh oh we'd like you to sample
some of our new cider oh so she drank it
oh she took one sip and then he asked
how it was and she said it's horrible
I'm not drinking another one it doesn't
even taste like cider because obviously
it's [ __ ] piss and then he told her
well he says I need to inform you of
something you just drank that man's
urine damn that's what I mean now this
this particular one was highly
prosecutable because that's what what do
they call it first degree wanton
endangerment yeah that's a class D
felony
so actually Merkel got arrested for that
one and they put him in jail for six
months because you don't know what
[ __ ] diseases you can get from roses
urine that's for testing um yeah so
there was a bunch of other ones where
they would call various hotels have them
break the windows you know set up fire
alarms all those kind of other kind of
[ __ ] there was also one on October 21st
I think also of 2009 or 2010 where one
of them I think it was Dex he called
Elizabeth Moreau who was a reporter for
ESPN and she was staying at a Hilton
Garden Inn in Gainesville Florida and he
got her to break the windows of her room
with the whole gas leak ruse then he
started a conference call with one of
the front desk employees of the hotel he
said that he was her boyfriend
and that the broken windows were because
they had had a fight so he was trying to
get her in trouble and also he made like
a bunch of you know sexually sexually
suggestive statements so the police got
involved in that [ __ ] too now this one
this happened in a motel 6 in
Spartanburg South Carolina this was in
November 2010 now there was an old guy
stay in the room he was an elderly
gentleman so one of the dudes calls says
he's a hotel administrator and he got
the guy to destroying his television set
he said that there was hidden cameras in
the room and that he had to break all
the mirrors because that the cameras
were behind there he said there was a
[ __ ] trapped in the adjoining room and
I'm saying [ __ ] because that's the
word they use he said there's a [ __ ]
trapped in the adjoining room and you
need to like try to bust out the wall
and like get him out so the guy like
kind of went down to the sheetrock like
trying to get this guy's and she that
yeah so I mean it wasn't gonna Coast it
was a no it was an old game yeah - now
um once that once the you know the cops
came and everything like that they
actually had heard some of the phone
call and everything so they actually
didn't charge the old guy for all the
damage to the room but they did tell him
to get the [ __ ] out of the house felt um
yes so apparently like I said motel 6
was kind of like a pretty common target
because at the time you could just call
into the you could just call into the
rooms without having to know the names
of the people you know that we're
staying in there um so here was another
one
this happened December 5th 2010 two of
the prank net members called a 22 year
old guy who is actually an Iraq war
veteran he was staying at a motel 6 in
Amarillo Texas one of them posed as the
hotel receptionist said that the prior
occupant of his room had been diagnosed
with h1n1 you know the flu virus yeah
and then he transferred him to the other
prank net caller who was posing as a
doctor
so he told the guy to induce vomiting
dan then he said to drink some of his
own pee Dan to kill the incubation
period then he said I need you to
collect a stool sample in a pillowcase
and bring it down to the front desk and
then either one of those same guys or
another pregnant member called the front
desk said he was that guy the victim
yeah and said I'm so pissed off with the
surface service that I'm bringing a
pillowcase full of my [ __ ] down to the
down to the front desk Dan so what
happened so yeah so the receptionist
like freaked out because she thought
this guy was coming down with a thing
full of poop she locked herself in the
office she called the police then the
police came and it's just so there was
just this whole like [ __ ] [ __ ]
then it was like so they didn't get
caught for this that's like that's the
[ __ ] thing and again the pranksters
called back later they actually called
when the cops were there yeah got them
he was Luke using an electronic voice
thing to like disguise his voice yeah
and he said that he was the mom of one
of the prank callers yeah and he got the
police to put the victim back on the
phone and made the victim describe the
prank back to him Dan posing as a mom of
her you know I mean it's like what the
[ __ ] is the matter with you what is the
matter with you yeah that was an
ambitious prank yeah now another thing
like other than all these shenanigans
that they're doing another thing that
they that he would do was that he would
essentially hijack phone numbers from
businesses in the US and have them
forwarded back to his own Skype account
so he could [ __ ] with people that were
calling that particular business so he
had called he actually did that to the
Olympic game farm in Port Angeles
Washington so he had that phone number
forwarded to his own Skype number and
when people called like asking for
information about the business
he would just make obscene sexual
comments he did the same thing with the
fun for all amusement park in Chula
Vista California also took over incoming
calls to the Best Western Hotel in
Jacksonville Florida that was for 12
hours during that special occasion
a woman called like an elderly woman
called asking if either her husband or
like a male friend of hers he was
supposed to be going and staying at the
hotel so she called the hotel to ask if
he had gotten there yet and he said oh
well he's in his room having sex with a
man and doesn't want to be disturbed oh
so did she believe it I don't know okay
but yeah I mean she thought she was
calmer because she was calling the
hotel's phone number yeah hijacked the
phone numbers these dudes were doing
some serious damage that's what I mean
this is some [ __ ] this is a pranks
this is [ __ ] criminal activity right
here yeah he would understand how a
young guy would think that she was funny
because it wasn't happening to them if
she was happening to them it would be
fun that's like and that's why I think
somebody needs to do this to them every
day until they die which hopefully
happens sooner or later but yeah so he
um did the same thing to a Hilton Garden
Inn in Tulsa Oklahoma he would like
people would call there thinking they
were calling the Hilton Garden Inn and
he was like oh well there's no shuttle
so take a cab and the hotel will
reimburse you yeah so of course when
they got there they were expecting to
get money back he also told other
callers just for shits and giggles that
the hotel was in the middle of a swine
flu outbreak and or that they were in
the middle of a hostage situation so fun
he would also here was another really
charming thing that some of them did
they would place lists that they would
place ads on Craigslist usually for kind
of like free things like you know big
toys or you know trampolines [ __ ] like
that and then when anybody called for
the stuff then they would get all kinds
of abuse usually racial epithets or
sexual rants one time they put they put
up an ad for like a free trampoline a
twelve-year-old girl called them and Dex
told her don't get pregnant by a black
man because they all have AIDS oh they
had to do with the trampoline nothing
okay they're just trying to get people
to call them so they can [ __ ] him a
twelve-year-old girl yeah [ __ ] you ah so
it's like Marvel especially what what
you would think that the jokes would
have something to do with that damn
trampoline no okay it's just random [ __ ]
they're not that clever yeah
Markel one thing that he would do was he
would actually troll craigslist ads
particularly women that were selling
like used toys or baby items or
something like that then he would call
them and he'd be like super nice like he
was gonna buy the stuff and he was
coming over there so could he have your
address and then once she gave him her
address you would say oh I'm coming over
there to rape you and kill your children
oh yeah so yeah [ __ ] special yeah now
as I said The Smoking Gun which is kind
of like an investigation website it's
only three guys but you know they kind
of they break up on it at least with the
Jerky Boys the [ __ ] was kind of Phi
that's I mean this [ __ ] is not funny
yeah not in the least but yeah so so
they started an investigation and as I
said the these prank net guys like we're
all about like who were a ghost we we
know how to like no we're not stupid and
we know how to like cover our tracks and
[ __ ] like that it took smoking gun about
seven weeks of investigating and they
found pretty much all of these dudes
they found their home address and
everything like that I [ __ ] love
there's like a three-page article on The
Smoking Gun woods there's a bunch of
them up right net like you know when one
of them gets arrested or something but
the one that's about them daxing Dex is
really funny because basically they
found out where this dude lived he lives
somewhere in Ontario he lives in this
dinky like $600 a month apartment with
his mom it's like it all was he 25 okay
he's probably older than that now I
think that he was 25 when they when they
in which I think was 2011 maybe or 2010
somewhere around there so they go to his
building which was at 1637 Assumption
Street they said it was just like this
she came at the address yeah well no it
was on the site the site is it's not
there anymore it burned okay um yes so
he calls and they they just thought this
was like the best because they go to his
house there were reporters right so they
go to his house and they wanted to
interview him they had interviewed him
before
like anonymously like before his before
his identity was known and he had been
very cocky about how much he hated cops
and it's like oh I'm doing this as a
public service I'm doing like social
engineering like to show you how stupid
people are and they'll fall for anything
and all this other kind of crap so he
thinks he's doing like some kind of
thought I don't think he really thinks
that I think he's just a douche but like
you know that was what he told them
anyway so the reporters found his
[ __ ] house where he lived with like I
said with his [ __ ] mom and they go to
his house and wanted to interview him
they said his mom made him the door of
this dingy little apartment and then she
like ran back in his room she and the
reporter said we could hear them like
whispering in his room and then she said
you know he doesn't want to come out and
so like he's in there with like garbage
bags over the window and stuff like that
and then this little [ __ ] ass
[ __ ]
called the cops call the cops and it's
like he they said they said it was so
funny because on his little show like
what he's doing I was it he's like oh
[ __ ] cops and the cops that's what I
mean so it's like as soon as there's
three reporters out there talking to him
he like they said they like he hides
behind his mommy and like called the
cops and all this other kind of [ __ ] so
they're harassing me and bloody blow and
all this other kind of [ __ ] the cops
came but they didn't do your mom that
was up I'm not really sure I mean she
seemed like she was protecting him but I
don't know if she knew exactly what he
was up to because that's the thing it's
like like I said he just seemed like
this dumpy loser that spent like all day
just playing video games in his mom's
[ __ ] apartment he didn't have a job
it's like as far as I know the only well
you got to have a lot of spare time on
your hands to come obviously and come up
with because he was doing this [ __ ] like
all the time cuz like I said it wasn't
just the pranks and that he'd put him on
YouTube it's like a lot of times he was
like live-streaming there's like live
chats and stuff like that so he was
then he would plan them he's putting all
these all this all this unused pent-up
energy towards his [ __ ] cape
yes he's [ __ ] capers yeah that's what
I mean so it's like yeah they so if like
I said please do it's a trouble do the
Manchus please go to The Smoking Gun
website website to read it because it's
just so funny because they thought it
was hilarious that he's like this [ __ ]
dude who's like his whole online persona
as Dex was this guy that just sat there
talking about everyone's [ __ ] and how
week everyone was and how much he hated
cops and or something like I said so and
then like he's just this idiot that like
[ __ ] as soon as as soon as his
[ __ ] investigators like show up to
like find out who he is he like hides
behind his bomb so you know the it's
just this whole [ __ ] thing by the way
Dex is real name is Tariq Malik he
denies it but that's pretty much who it
is everybody says that's who it is yeah
so other than him there's this other
dude and like I said I wanted to get
into this a little bit cuz this is the
type of person that you're dealing with
right um as I said Dex he didn't like
have a job or anything he had had like
some kind of employment like earlier
like I think he ran kind of like a game
server type of thing but it kind of went
under and he didn't he had to move back
in with his mom and he was all know each
other there online
I just don't because most of them live
in do only the two top guys live in
Canada um but it's the other there's one
other famous trainer no it's just like
it's a it's like an online community so
yes so that was him
the second in command is called William
Marquis and his [ __ ] screen name was
hemp stir because of course it was okay
now at the time all this [ __ ] was going
on this dude was like 51 okay so this is
like all the other dudes in their 20s so
it's like this skeevy [ __ ] is
like online like hanging up dude this
shit's like you're too old for that [ __ ]
come on man he's probably like sixties
now I wonder if he knew how young the
other guys work oh I'm sure yeah it's
like what the [ __ ] you did have anything
else to do so he's gonna go I guess not
now he had
when he was doxxed by smoking gun that
he they found that he had two prior
convictions one 2004 for drunk driving
also one in 2005 for marijuana
production they also took great delight
in pointing out that when he was
convicted of growing marijuana that he
cried when the conviction was right how
much time did you do now
James Markel the guy like I said who
like to call women on Craigslist and
threatened that he was going to rape
them and kill their children yeah was
actually one of the most prolific
callers and members a pregnant he was
actually arrested for one of the prank
calls to McDonald's now this guy also
[ __ ] special when they found out who
he was he also had a prior conviction as
a juvenile for raping a five-year-old
girl damn and telling her that he was
going to kill her if she told anyone
yeah so his threats mate there was some
truth behind it he did rape
[ __ ] yeah Danny more than one
of them too and women and children were
not safe around Dan uh what was he like
physically though how old was he
this guy was I think when he was
arrested he was 21 OC was a kid yes like
I said they were pretty much just all in
their 20s except for that one creepy old
[ __ ]
yeah um another one along the same lines
was named Sean Powell he had also
previously been imprisoned for indecency
with a minor he had taken nude photos of
an eight-year-old female relative so he
had actually has a bottle that's what I
mean these are just a bunch of scumbags
his big specialty was a racist phone
calls and also threatening phone calls
threatening women with rape and whatnot
yeah he was also charged with criminal
mischief for his part in one call to the
bay town Arby's restaurant where the
fire suppression system was set off now
interestingly there were a couple of
women in this collective that did
participate early on in some of the
crank phone calls before they got to off
the rails but they were kind of like
around the fringes it was mostly a dude
thing like you said probably the most
significant female member was named
Jericho Batsford now she was older she
was
in her 30s or 40s I believe at the time
most of this was going on she was
actually a widow she had a teenage son
and she had been in the Navy she was she
had done some of the crank phone calls
early on she said her specialty was
calling pharmacies and like [ __ ] with
the pharmacist and stuff like that but
after there were there were a couple
incidents where the prank callers would
try to get like minors like people under
18 to like call in bomb threats and
things like that and she was just kind
of like yeah she's like nah man I'm out
yeah so now predictably
after she left she actually reported Dex
and all them she reported them to the
FBI which good for her yeah um and
predictably they tried to [ __ ] with her
they tried to call Child Protective
Services and say that she beat her kid
to getting taken away they called a
hotel and said that a male rapist with
her name was running around so they
tried to like you know link her name
with a rapist um she I kind of read a
little bit of an interview with her and
she was saying you know at that time in
my life I was kind of like [ __ ] up I
was going through a lot of stuff it's
like I I needed a laugh and I couldn't
find anything funny except cruelty so
she thought that was funny for a while
but then it kind of like went too far
and she's worn off yeah it kind of like
and she's like now [ __ ] that and she did
like turn them in she did admit that she
had made some prank phone calls to some
of the fast-food restaurants to
pharmacies and stuff like that you know
and she had also given money to some of
the other members like to pay for some
of their servers and some of their
computer equipment and stuff which is a
couple of other women did - it's like
some of them didn't even make any phone
calls they just participated in the
chats and would like give some of these
losers money when they needed it you
know what I mean because I have to say
that Dex tarik Malek his apartment
building burned down later on and some
of the people in the chat room like did
get blip because of course he cried
about it's like almost stuff is gone
like he saved his laptop but that's
about it but of course he like [ __ ]
cried cuz
house burned down and oh poor me poor me
and some of the people in the chat room
like did give him money and [ __ ] like
that like wire them money and all that
other kind of crap
so as far as I know a couple of the like
at least two of them are in jail or
served time for that for whatever reason
[ __ ] Dex is still running around free
and as far as I know that Markie dude is
as well but there are charges pending
against some of them in four US states
and six US cities they're probably all
land and they're and they're thinking
about you know extraditing that's from
Canada to like you know face charges in
various cities so they're all laying low
right now yeah now as far as I know like
I said I didn't want to look too much
into it looks like a lot of the pranked
if you search prank net on YouTube it
looks like a lot of their videos are
still there yeah but like I said I don't
want to give him any of you so I don't
watch any of them so I don't know how
old any of them were so I don't know if
they're really like since they've all
been doxxed it seems like it kind of
fell apart like they're not really doing
it anymore but maybe they still are
because everybody knows where they are
now and everybody knows their names
they're being watched
yeah the end you check up on them that's
what I mean and I kind of feel like
after that happened like after The
Smoking Gun like said all their names
and their addresses and [ __ ] like that
Dex still came into the chat rooms from
time to time but he was like super wary
of like new people coming into the chat
room because he thought all of them were
like journalists or you know FBI agents
or cops or whatever and they were like
trying to get him to like say some [ __ ]
so he's probably not far from wrong well
yeah he's probably right yeah but so I
don't know how active any of this [ __ ]
is now you know what I mean because then
years just probably probably not doing
anything now and um I think at least one
of them one of them that did jail time
said that he felt really bad about it
and like you know I was going through a
rough time
people think online is the online world
is anonymous it is it know everything
you do not have already found they can
find you they can find you they can
listen to you through your devices and
they're starting to admit that now it's
just like I said it seemed to me and the
whole reason it's like the whole reason
a lot of these prank net members allowed
them to even when they were still
anonymous they allowed themselves to be
interviewed by various websites because
they thought no one would ever find out
who they were because they thought they
were [ __ ] smart more [ __ ] smart
reah they found you dumbass so before we
go I think roads can roll away at 42
minutes so we still got time since I you
know talked about them some I wanted to
talk a little bit about obedient studies
and what has been done in that
department because that really does seem
to line up with this topic because of
people doing stuff that some random
jackoff tells you on the phone right you
know what I mean
yeah and that kind of [ __ ] is always
really interested me like the psychology
behind it well they were actually what
calling Child Protective Services and
cops and getting them to do yeah what
they wanted to do so that's what maybe
and I feel like it's really like you
know anybody can sit here and say oh I
wouldn't have done this that the other
thing if somebody just called and told
me that but it's like until you're in
that situation I don't know if you
really know and like I said that's why I
kind of want to talk a little bit about
the Milgram experiment because a lot of
people before they did that experiment
nobody they pulled or asked or anything
every said nanana I wouldn't I wouldn't
do any of that [ __ ] but a lot of them
did you know Romania a lot of them did
yeah and that's what I think is weird is
that they can call the authorities and
get the authorities to do [ __ ] like all
that you know swatting yeah yeah that's
what I mean that's like [ __ ] up so
it's not just like people being dummies
or whatever it's like if you call and
sound authoritative enough and sound
like you know what you're doing and the
request you're making doesn't sound
super crazy and still sounds kind of
reasonable then I think probably yeah
85 90 percent of the time you will get
that person to do at least some of what
you say that whole swatting thing I
think they can dip that in the but if
you just have to if you make it so the
call can't be anonymous well yeah you
know but evidently need they will accept
an anonymous call because you know the
SWAT teams have showed up at these
places they killed that dude yeah that's
on the words of somebody else who made a
false allegation I don't know how
how a state can put up with that you
know I mean if you're gonna make an
allegation against somebody and SWAT
them they should at least know who you
are
well yeah clear stuff they go down there
and [ __ ] you they kill that dude and
they know then it turns out that it was
all the false allegation you need to be
held accountable if you ask me yeah I
know you know I don't know how yeah
that's what I mean it's like this is why
this is something that was always really
fascinating too because I took like a
whole bunch of psychology classes like
in high school of college everything
like that and this is something that is
always really fascinating to me all
these studies about obedience and
conformity and stuff like that like how
how many people will do [ __ ] when they
know that it's bad or they know that
it's wrong that [ __ ] kills me they're
doing it because they know it's wrong
they like the fact that it's wrong I
don't know if that's entirely what's
going on though I mean it might be in
some cases but I mean okay so if you've
taken any psychology in school you will
have heard of the Milgram experiment
they made a movie about it in 2015
there's a documentary about it that's
called obedience so Stanley Milgram he
kind of got interested in he had been
doing kind of work in this area for a
while but he got interested in doing
this particular experiment after the
Nuremberg trials because I think it was
Adolf Eichmann that said something about
how he was just following orders or
something like that
so Milgram wanted to see how that could
happen
like how somebody could just be
following orders and could do something
that they thought was harmful or was
against their moral code so he was kind
of interested in exploring that Avenue
so um as you probably know the first one
that he did and like I said they say the
Milgram experiment was actually a series
of experiments they did like a whole
bunch with different experimental
protocols to try different things out
but the first one of most famous was
actually 40 guys they did it at Yale
University and basically what they would
do is they would have the guys come in
but then there would be so there would
be them who was like the victim and then
everyone else would be like an
accomplice you know I mean but the the
victim didn't know that so you'd have
the experimenter which was the person
that was in charge of the session the
teacher this was the victim now the
teacher
thought that there would be another
person in there who was the
quote-unquote learner but when you came
in him and the learner came in at the
same time so he thought this was someone
else that was doing the experiment he
didn't know it was an actor he didn't
know that they were all in cahoots so
but they made it look like it was random
you know what a man like they would draw
who's the teacher who's the learner but
both of them said teacher but the other
guy said oh I'm the learner you know I
mean so the teacher was always the same
person so they would come in and they
were told that the study was to they
were going to study the effect of
punishment on learning basically what
you had to do was the teacher had to
read a series of word pairs to the
learner and if the learner got the word
pairs incorrect then you were supposed
to administer a shock of increasing
voltage every time they got something
wrong and there's this big very famous
box it's in like a museum and [ __ ] like
that nowadays because it's very famous
starting out I think they start out with
15 volts and then went all the way up to
450 volts which the Machine very clearly
set on it danger like fatal dose or
something like that so you know so you
knew what you were getting into now
before they did the study also they
would actually give the teacher who was
actually the subject of the experiment
they would give them a minor shock which
actually did hurt so they're like okay
well that was only 45 volts so they
could get a feeling of what it would
feel like so they would start reading
these word pairs to the learner
unbeknownst to them the learner was
supposed to get particular ones wrong at
particular stages in the experiment so
that the teacher would shock them now
obviously the learner was not really
being shocked mmm they just had like a
tape or whatever of the learner like
reacting to the shocks in increasingly
distressed ways now at 300 volts the
learner would stop responding to the
questions implying that they had either
been shocked into unconsciousness or
were dead
so at this point you know the teachers
would be like the
or the experimenter would say to them
will you have to continue if they don't
answer that means that's a wrong answer
so you just have to keep shocking them
now prior to Milgram doing this
experiment like before he had even done
it he he had like the you know protocol
of it written up and everything like
that and he surveyed psychology students
he surveyed other psychologists he
surveyed a whole bunch of people and he
said how many people do you think will
go all the way up to 450 volts the
average people thought that it would be
1.2 percent they said oh no people won't
do that mmm wrong oh yeah
no frying most of them will 65% went all
the way up to not just one time three
times 450 volts now I should note that
every single participant did question
the experiment was like I don't really
want to do this anymore [ __ ] like that
so all of them did protest all of them
were clearly very stressed out some of
them started crying some of them started
having seizures they all had very you
know very high stress reactions so
obviously they were very stressed out
about it and yet most of them continued
anyway even though there was really no
punishment for them leaving now
interestingly what so what they had set
up they did get paid for participating
in this experiment I think they got
$4.50 or something like that which was I
mean this was 1961 or whatever it was so
there was a lot more money than it
sounds like but they were told like look
if you don't want to do this thing you
would stop the experiment at any time
but if the person protested the
experimenter had four very particular
things that they would say in this order
the first thing they would say the first
protest that the person made they would
just say please continue the second time
that they protested they would say the
experiment requires that you continue
the third time they would say it is
absolutely essential that you continue
the
first time you have no other choice you
must go on as I said 65% of the people
and these were all they were all men the
first one aged between 20 and 50 so yeah
so 65% of them did go off now every
single one of them went at least to 300
which was when the learner stopped
responding to the questions
yeah but 65% of them went all the way to
450 volts and hit the person 450 volts
three times now they did they also did
variations of this experiment they did
something with mixed genders they did
some with women they did them all over
like different countries to see if like
maybe different people in different
countries had a different reaction
pretty much they always got about the
same thing the only thing that made a
difference was a couple of factors if
the teacher you know the subject of the
experiment if they could see the learner
if they were in the same room as them
compliance went way down if they had to
touch the learner for example put their
arm physically on the plate that was
supposedly electrocuting them then it
went way way down you know so the fact
that they could see them you know that
that made a big difference how close
they were also how far away the
experimenter was if the experimenter was
in the same room as them or was in
another room also they put another
experimenter in there who wanted to stop
the experiment that would kind of spur
more people to say they didn't want to
do it anymore
so there was a lot of other factors that
they worked with but generally every
time this experiment has been replicated
it's been about the same between 60 and
66 percent when using these same
protocols we'll go all the way to 450
million people like have a really
intense are really really good hobby
about making themselves feel morally
superior to other people who kind of
lose in history telling you if your
group tells you you have to do something
for the betterment of your
or for the survival of your group you'll
do it most likely yeah and they think
that how it is well see if it's an
authority figure doesn't matter what
side of the aisle are you you are on if
your group tells you you have to do this
it's the right thing to do you'll
probably do it when I was in the Army
depending on the context if somebody
said Ross you have to kill that woman
I'd probably do it if the context made
sense
yes something totally out of context no
but you know if it was in context with
the battlefield then I would have done
it well and that's what he was trying to
show that I mean these were authority
figures they were telling you no they
appeared to be doctors they were at Yale
University although I should say that
they did do a variation in the
experiment that was in like an unlike it
on you know an office that didn't have
any affiliation because they wanted to
see if oh maybe it's cuz Yale and they
have more authority and stuff and
actually compliance did go down a bit to
45% rather than 65% when it was just in
a generic random office rather than Yale
University but what that's what he
wanted to show was that if you have
someone there who is an authority figure
telling you this is for you know a
scientific experiment you have to keep
doing it and there's also the sense to
where he kind of went it his two things
he's like there's either two
interpretations of this experiment um
the first one being conformism you know
and I kind of want to get into like
Solomon Asch and his conformity
experiments to which were a lot less
drastic than this but it kind of shows a
similar thing whereas you know in that
sense this is like a situation where
nobody wants to rock the boat you know
it's like this is what we're supposed to
do and we're just gonna do it we're just
gonna leave the decision-making to you
know the person in authority because
clearly they know what they're doing
whereas the other thing is called the
agentic state theory where the person is
essentially giving up their own
individuality
to someone else who is responsible
because if you watch the documentary
called obedience and one guy and maybe
it was more than one guy but they did
show one guy saying that specifically he
said if that guy is dead or if that guy
is hurt are you taking responsibility he
said to the quote/unquote doctor so the
fact that someone else was claiming
responsibility for killing these people
you know or so they thought that kind of
made people feel better because it's
like oh well even if the dudes dead I
won't be blamed for it so there was some
of that [ __ ] going on - yeah now this
study obviously I don't think you'd be
able to do it now it has been replicated
with various other protocols nowadays
you can't really do it without some of
the things change because of ethics and
whatnot you'd have to give people like
more of a debriefing afterward and [ __ ]
then and they really got on this one
although I should say that most of the
people who participated in this
experiment 84 percent of them when
polled afterwards said they were very
glad that they even though it was very
stressful for them at a time that they
were very glad they have participated in
it because it showed them something
about themselves that they were happy to
know and actually Milgram got a bunch of
letters from people that have
participated in the experiment saying
like thanking him for doing it so even
though it did stress them out at the
time they were actually happy to have
done it because they learned something
about themselves and about human nature
and they thought that was kind of cool
whom humans are weird III don't really
like using the example of the Nazis
because they've just been overused and
it's a very tainted subject I like to
better I think it's I think using the
Japanese as an example is a lot better
because it's not quite as volatile the
Japanese were running around in World
War two cutting people's heads off with
swords a lot of them were women
civilians okay and you look at it in a
modern context you know men that's damn
insane how the hell do you tell 19 year
old boys go out to cut some woman's head
off well in the context of the of what
they were ordered to do
in the situation they thought it was the
right thing to do and it's just amazing
how you how your own group can convince
you of that it's the right Ben dude
that's a woman's head off the thing
about it is that here's the thing and
and I was kind of thinking about this
earlier because I watched like a [ __ ]
ton of documentaries about this and read
a [ __ ] ton about this is that a little
bit of obedience is good I mean let's
use it let's use the obvious example of
traffic laws if everyone just drove
their car wherever the [ __ ] they wanted
to obviously it would be chaos everyone
would be killed and everything like that
so you have to obey traffic laws to have
anything resembling a normal commute to
work or whatever however what they were
interested in exploring is that you know
obviously these people that thought they
were shocking the person they were very
morally conflicted
they were clearly upset like I said some
of them had [ __ ] seizures some of
those little crying and [ __ ] like that
and did not want to do it but still kept
doing it anyway so they were like that's
really the power of Authority and how
many people go along with it now I
should note that this original study the
Milgram's experiment was done in 1961
now when they did the same experiment
later on like in the 70s and 80s and
stuff like that compliance was much less
so some people have thought that you
know one to you know obviously the
outcome of the experiment was better
known but um because late 60s early 70s
was more like a questioning authority
type of thing like more people were used
to that whereas you know 50s and 60s was
very kind of like oh we all have to be
like conformist and like we have to do
what people tell us to do and all this
other kind of [ __ ] so they think maybe
there was some of that [ __ ] going on too
now I should say too that I think like
the BBC they have that illusionist
Derren Brown he replicated this
experiment also in the 2000s I think it
was and I and I saw like part of that on
his show the heist he got pretty much
the same results um I do feel like it
was one [ __ ] psycho on there I maybe
he knew about the experiment he was just
[ __ ] with it because it was on the
show or whatever but he went all the way
up to the 400
50 and then he's like you need more
buttons you know I mean like he was
upset that there weren't more buttons so
he could shock the dead person more I
guess but like I said maybe that guy
knew about maybe he knew his fake that's
what I mean maybe he knew about the
experiment and he knew what they were
testing because I feel like the Milgram
experiment it's like I don't even know
if you could do it nowadays without
super super hiding it like your motive
because obviously everybody knows what
that is now yeah so I don't know if
you're gonna get like a non tainted yeah
kind of thing anymore oh that was just
experiments yeah I want to look at
realistic examples I just kind of asked
the audience to do the research on the
Battle of Nanjing which is between Japan
and China and find out what happened
there and you'll just be damn appalled
well as what humans well damn do yeah
okay and think that it's the right thing
to do yeah I mean and we're talking
extremes okay Battle of Nanjing well and
the thing about it is that and it
involved lots of civilians yeah okay and
some people have kind of not well
criticized Milgram's experiment because
like I said he got interested in
studying like you know what people would
do like if Authority told them to
because of the Nazis yeah but a lot of
people said well it's not exactly
analogous because you know the Nazis you
know a lot of them had that whole had
that whole like you know we hate Jews
thing like going back for like centuries
and so it was kind of like ingrained in
that ideology and a lot of them too they
said now some of the ones that maybe
we're doing the [ __ ] and weren't like
you know super jazzed about it they
might have been afraid that they would
be killed if they didn't do what they
were told was peer pressure right so
it's like so they so the people that
were you know involved in this
experiment obviously didn't have that
pressure they didn't think that the
experimenter was gonna kill them if they
didn't like keep going with the
experiment but I don't know it's like I
still think it's an interesting insight
because the fact that so many of them
kept going anyway even though they could
have left there was a really good
program I saw on Netflix that was I
believe that was Netflix
the British had a damn castle alright
that they used as a prison for
high-value Germans and this castle was
bugged I mean it had in microphones all
over it and really what they kind of had
a cover story that they were there to be
kind of protected and interviewed but
the real purpose of this high quality
prison alright was to record the voices
and the conversations of all these Nazis
and they told stories about the stuff
that they saw a lot of it on the Eastern
Front and also the very early part of
the final solution most of it where
there was wiping out Slavic people all
right and the conversation is that they
had very interesting
they were very disturbed by what they
were doing very disturbed by it but
because it was orders they did it well
yeah and in a way that's why in some
ways I know that it's not exactly
analogous you know to Milgram's
experiment but clearly everyone that was
involved in the Holocaust was not happy
about what they were they didn't like
what they were doing and we're like
stressed out just like the people in the
Milgram experiment blowing their own
heads off a lot yeah a lot of [ __ ] and
which he prior these weird conflicts of
like I know this is wrong but they're
telling me to do it I did it anyway
they say it's helping our civilization
yeah probably exactly what I don't
really like it I'm out of here a lot of
them were shooting themselves in the
head
and that's why the death camps were
invented it was to save the German
soldiers from having to kill people now
you know yeah because they're like
making it it was never killing
themselves the death camps were a lot of
people don't really know how death camps
worked death camps were basically run by
German confident convicts called Capo's
and they were gonna be killed too and
then they had Jewish labour running it
prisoner labour running it the only
people that really kind of had anything
I guess you could say quote freedom to
move were certain very special SS type
officers and they were probably to kill
them too
I can't see how they would let them live
that's what I mean so so even though
like I said it's a similar thing and you
can see like the conflict with a lot of
the video because obviously everyone is
not an evil [ __ ] and most people
you know obviously devs can't person
ELLs were selected for being [ __ ]
psychos yeah I mean there's a lot of
[ __ ] in the world but most people
can't do that job can't do that right
which thankfully I gotta think that they
were gonna kill all those Capo's and
kill all those SS guys that knew about
those programs and then they were gonna
erase that they were gonna erase the
fact that those camps had ever existed
yeah most of them were in Poland yeah
the Germans weren't seeing them yeah I
mean I can't see how they would let let
those let those uh those staff members
survive yeah I mean if you were gonna do
that would you let those guys live well
yeah that's something I wouldn't they
were there would be too dangerous to let
live yeah and then they've gotten to
tell people about it
yeah no I think they were gonna kill a
ball yeah and erase it you know but yeah
so like I said I think that you know
some people have made the criticism but
Milgram was like you know I was just
trying to establish the extension with
people who weren't even threatened to
had complete freedom to leave if they
wanted to and we're told as such you
know that they would still do what they
were told even if they thought they were
killing another person you know a large
percentage of them would do that I also
wanted to get a little bit into like I
said something a little less freaky the
Solomon Asch conformity experiments now
like I said this wasn't as unethical you
know what guess it sounds super
unethical but like I said you can't
really do it the same anymore they've
you know they've got different protocols
in place now but this actually happened
in 1951 and Milgram was actually really
interested in this as well now in this
experiment what they would do is they
would have one person come in and they'd
be in a room with a bunch of other
people that they thought were other
people you know participating in this
experiment which they called a quote
unquote vision test
now what this one person didn't know was
that all the other people were actors
they were all Confederates that this
person was the only one that they were
experimenting on they wanted to see the
power of conformity the power of peer
pressure they called it a vision test
what they would do is they would hold up
two pieces of paper one piece of paper
had one line on it and the other piece
of paper had three lines on it of
different lengths basically all you had
to do is you had to say ok which line on
this you know paper with three lines on
it is the same length as this line and
the right answer was very very obvious
but all the Confederates in the room the
actors had been told to give the wrong
answer and they wanted to see if the one
person would go along with the group
knowing that that was the wrong answer
guess what you can get a [ __ ] to
boot most of them days yeah most of them
did yeah and I'm telling you these
intelligence agencies advertising
companies and corporations know about
this they use this against us yeah they
use this well like I said ok so they see
all kinds of stuff that isn't true yeah
they did 18 trials now some now on some
of them because they didn't want to be
too fishy so the Confederates would give
the correct answer on some of them on
six of the trials they gave the correct
answer however on 12 of the trials they
gave the wrong answer what was clearly
the wrong answer
now so each person that participated 32
percent which is a little bit less than
I thought it would be 32 percent of the
people that were placed in this
situation went along on all the trials
and gave the wrong answer 75% of the
people conformed at least once if not
all the times however there were a rebel
25% who never went along they always
knew what the right answer wasn't
they're like that's just the right
answer [ __ ] but when they
interviewed the people afterward they
asked him why did you get the wrong
answer like when you knew it was the
wrong answer pretty much all of them I
think they gave like 1% of people just
Burgess Dom and thought it was thought
that was the right answer
all of the other people asked they said
they knew it was the wrong answer but
they didn't want they either didn't want
people looking at them weird like they
didn't want people like they didn't want
to
standout because everyone else cuz you
had to give the answers out loud you had
to say like a B or C so it's like they
didn't want everyone to think they were
weird or didn't want to go along with
people or they started to question their
own judgement like everyone else says
it's that maybe I'm wrong maybe I'm not
seeing it right you know what I mean so
most of the people did have like a lot
of cognitive dissonance about it because
they pretty much knew that it was the
wrong answer but it's just like really
it's bizarre how many of the people
would go along with it I don't think I
would do that I'm not sure about the
shock thing I don't think I would have
done that but everybody says that the
conformity thing I'd have been the first
thing I would have thought is that when
they started giving the wrong answer to
the line I'd be like yellow [ __ ]
yeah you know if you're just a college
student a faculty member you're gonna
see as an authority figure okay but you
know if you're older or you're gonna
have a different perception of these
people I'm next military I just don't
see civilians as Authority so I would be
like man what are you doing you know I'm
right
so blind right I'll blind people right I
tend to kind of want to take charge I
don't want to listen I want to take
charge you know you have to be stronger
and more frightening than me to be in
charge or no III only rule and can be
ruled by fear that's it if I'm not
afraid of you then I'm in charge you're
smart
in your ear you're a lied to me I was
like don't you pull anything I know I
know it like that line is how I she
knows how I am I do I've known I've
known him a very very long it means that
I mean even before we were going out we
were we were like best friends really
yeah yeah our relationship came from
friendship anyway even though we're like
total opposites
yes it's really really funny because
total opposite now total offices just
that were good team because yeah I can
see things she can't she can see things
that I can't then we work it out yeah
but it but interestingly in this
conformity study pretty much just like
in the Milgram experiment if there were
other factors introduced like if they
introduced another person just one more
person who gave the right
answer then then most of the you know
subjects would give the right answer
then because they had like a buddy you
know what I mean it's like oh I'm not
crazy it's like that's their you know
you're you're my friend and we'll both
give the right answer but I just thought
that was really interesting the way I
don't know like I said I'd cuz you can
look at the [ __ ] [ __ ] the line is
clearly you can see what the answer is
they wanted something that was very very
clearly the correct answer I don't think
you could get me sitting in a room full
of people to go along with abundant
idiots who don't know 100s
all right you can do to me either like I
said I know everybody says that but I'm
not good I'm used to sitting around cuz
I think everyone's idiots anyway yeah
I'm used to being in a room where people
don't the [ __ ] they're talking about
right exactly when they know I just
appointed okay I just assume everyone's
dumb no or they can't see right I'm used
to it
I understand the low IQ world it's like
I was kind of thinking about that you
know it in regards to like the Milgram
experiment because I was thinking would
I have shocked a person I'd like to
think not but it's like a lot of those
people thought they wouldn't do and they
did anyway when they were in that
situation I would like to think I'd be
like [ __ ] this I'm out but I don't know
I don't know you know what I mean yeah
I'm not worried about it it's hard to
say I was I don't this is what 1960 what
1961 though I was even born so yeah but
they've done it other times since then
like I said and also yes I think with
depending on what phase of life I was in
if I was in my early 20s cheerio then
maybe I would fall for that but by the
time 25 26 had rolled around no I
wouldn't fall for that yeah because
military service makes you skeptical I
think I might have done it when I was
young because not so much that it's just
that you know when you're younger maybe
you're more like eager to please
especially if you're a girl but now that
I'm old and all you know [ __ ] about
anything anymore
military nope gets you very used to the
idea that there is good leadership and
bad leadership yeah you know I mean and
then you're looking for good and strong
leaders that are correct
and you know how to weed out weak
leaders that are always incorrect you
know we can see him yeah because we've
had them yeah you've seen them be
eliminated you know by the system so we
know like I said I'd be interested to
see I know they did a bunch of
variations by gender and things like
that
you know in the original study it was a
pretty wide age range I'd be interested
if younger people are older people would
be more slow I'm going through this I'll
be like well what is the mission where
are we trying to achieve and what are
the limits so one of the parameters in
this mission if this person dies who's
responsible well one guy though
at least one guy did ask that way even
on the in the original experiment the
idea like you know who's legally who's
legally responsible this person dies
who's funding this mission yeah so you
know I mean there's there's overarching
questions that you have to ask well
band-aid an answer that [ __ ] then yeah
man you guys are full of [ __ ] man they
did answer they didn't ask most of them
they said pretty much all of them all of
them question the experiment at one
point another so all of them did right
all of them either said something like
who is responsible if does it hurt them
who is responsible if they get hurt am i
rival
they said they all did ask questions
like that but most wanna know I wanna
know you they would have to get me on
board yeah does this person know that
they can they can die who you know what
are we trying to achieve here what
Corporation has hired this why do they
have to die I mean I have to know the
whole damn thing yeah before I can do
this why are you pressing the button you
know that's something that I would have
to aren't you [ __ ] games like the
others you want even me for to do is
down press a button
what do you need me for yeah you know so
I didn't really I would have immediately
kind of thought of that like I think you
could do this experiment again but you
would have to totally change the furnace
you would have to like change you can't
do like the shock buttons anymore
because like you said most people would
ask that very obvious question why can't
you do it yeah you press it you press
yeah if I gotta press it then that means
I'm center of attention something's
wrong here yeah
why does me press in it why does that
make a difference yeah yeah yeah why is
this damn bud
he doesn't it's fishy yeah you know yeah
you very fishy and even at 20 I think 20
by my in my early twenties out of it
this is some fishy [ __ ] yeah because my
little twenty year old ass as pretty as
I am not pretty ass pressing this
[ __ ] but I got a full grown as a man
with a clipboard in a white coat what do
you need me to press this button for
yeah why am i is it buddy looking at me
cuz that's how I would yeah yeah it's
like a job nobody can blame me for that
[ __ ] yeah I was dumb but I wasn't that
dumb at 21 yeah I wasn't that dumb I
mean cuz why would they need me for
right yeah yeah pushing a button in the
nard got all kinds of people that can
press buttons
a monkey could press the monkey
compressor but I got a great clipboard
standing right there you do it yeah
detected something was wrong yeah it
seems obvious in hindsight it's like I
wonder if anybody did ask that I did
they did answer ask like other questions
that you asked but I don't know anybody
why do you need me yeah yeah exactly
like you need a patsy or something right
you're just gonna kill this [ __ ]
person right screaming I would have
thought that yeah why do you want me to
kill this person you know like I don't
even know you guys yeah you want to wash
your hands of it
yeah that would seem like and then put
it on me yeah you know I wouldn't have
thought that they were right I had to be
honest I wouldn't have thought that
there was no voltage yeah I would have
thought it was some kind of thing where
they wanted like the ability to legally
deny that they were responsible well
nowadays you would think of it like it
would be like some kind of weird [ __ ]
horror movie like SARS shot then like
you're being manipulated by a serial
killer thought it was some kind of
liability tank and I'd be like
I get sued right you know like this [ __ ]
euro 50 q4 50s I don't want the cops on
you I don't know how much that is in
2000 $19 so that's probably our alright
so how long will be going on oh my
goodness for a very long time I thought
I thought we might I didn't even get to
all the [ __ ] that I was gonna but I got
that [ __ ] down I got to most of it oh
okay shut that [ __ ] down I command it
well now I'm not gonna do it just gotta
make you really satisfy you've been
trolling I'm just gonna keep it going
although I'm gonna say hilarious I don't
care just because I don't like being
okay I'll just sit here it's radius all
right so we are wrapping up 160 episode
hundred and 60 that is hope you enjoyed
it was it like I said we kind of covered
a lot of ground and I didn't get into as
much detail as I wanted about some of
the things but that's okay it kind of
gave you a little bit of a overview of
all these various cases so hope you guys
had fun we sure did remember if you like
the show like share subscribe go to
patreon if you want to support us or you
can go to our blog there's a little
button to donate through PayPal if you
would like to do that give it one time
nation really does help us a lot and we
will see you on the next episode
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]